[Music]
foreign
let's go
[Music]
foreign
a storm is brewing Dimitri on Jacob
Drake is a wizard within the Tempest the
best have come to test their skills and
brave the storm oh we missed it
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the magic
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby exhausting every last
resource the battles will be Electric
oh tactic the moves will be fast it's
game over it's winning oh my God he's
gonna make a queen the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
we are live we are here the 2022 speed
Chess Championship rolls on
International Master Danny wrench
getting to hop in for his first match of
the Year alongside Grand Master Dania
noradiskey Donya are you pumped for
today the world champion jumping into
The Fray I'm super pumped Danny good
morning everybody good afternoon
depending on where you are you finally
got rid of this Robert Hess guy so I'm
even more excited like that finally it's
about time Danny
I accidentally rhymed there world
champion jumping in today into The Fray
it's gonna be an awesome day oh my god
let's uh let's read away here and remind
everybody of what they're what they're
about to watch here with the speed Chess
Championship it's uh it's the event you
know and love and we are in the round of
16 100 Grand at stake for all of your
competitors it's two thousand dollars to
the winner outright and then the rest of
the money is split by win percentage one
of my favorite things about it keeps the
match interesting throughout a little
bit of cash on the line the winner of
course will advance to the quarterfinals
uh Dania of course we're going to be
talking a lot about what we think needs
to happen for dama Raju cash to have a
chance to move on to the quarterfinals
but before we do your thoughts on how
the SCC format has been delivering so
far oh it's it's been delivering on
every front I mean all Chambers are
filled for each of these players I
always say this before every match they
don't need any additional incentive
especially when you're facing the world
champion just you know a job well done
is its own reward in the SCC but I am
also a very big fan of the price
distribution and the way that it
encourages competitive play even when
the result of the match itself has been
decided
well and for the most part the matches
have been very close let's yeah dive
into the bracket right and talk about
who moved on of course I was a fan
watching you and Robert uh bring home
the Armageddon spectacle that was
levonne aronian's victory over Dimitri
on draken but in regards to the other
three competitors who've already punched
their ticket to the quarters uh what has
stood out to you so far Donya as a guy
who's commentated on more than any
anyone
yeah I mean from a purely sporting
perspective I think uh mvl's performance
cannot be underestimated I mean he beats
you on the Promise You by eight points
he blows them out of the water in
precisely the format when most people
thought the opposite would happen that
was an insane performance but obviously
from an entertainment standpoint you
would be crazy to not go for aronian and
Drake and as the matchup of the SEC
season thus far but the good news is
that we've got plenty more matches uh
that that match will have to compete
with
yeah and of course doing the red getting
bike okay I I'm not gonna go uh Fanboy
fan girl here and just talk about all
the matches I had because I wanted to
jump in the ring and talk about maybe
there was more to meet the eye with mvl
having a stylistic advantage over Yan it
was a very weird match to watch but okay
let's talk about today's match I don't
think this is going to be a weird one to
watch everyone knows that the world
chess champion Magnus Carlson is making
his debut against the young Indian
rising star damaraju gukesh uh Johnny
take it away what are the things that
jump out to you about this matchup on
paper and what we're about to see listen
I think as commentators it's important
to be realistic I would love to say that
chances are this is going to be a very
close match it's going to come down to
the Armageddon on paper that's not very
likely to be the case Magnus Carlson is
Magnus Carlson but something you like to
point out Danny I'm sure you'll expand
on this kukesh has defeated Magnus
Carlson in serious rapid play before
he's on an upswing people forget that
his feet a rating he's something like
27.25 so this guy is a full-fledged
member of the super GM Club Danny and
he's not an easy opponent for anybody
and he's young so that votes very well
for him given the format what you
touched on I think the major point there
whenever you have young players you
don't quite know what they're capable of
we'll be talking about these story lines
throughout the day but damaraju agukesh
has also not even played that much
online chess in the last year uh he's
been very focused on his classical and
Rapid form uh the last couple days he's
really been throwing down though
um and and so what exactly is the
youngster capable of in these fast time
controls uh but I'm with you you got to
be realistic in talking about this
matchup the world chess champion is is
is that for a reason
um he's also won most of the matches
he's ever played in the SEC for a reason
and so this should be a very interesting
interesting matchup to see whether
gukesh strikes early I think I'll say
that dukesh has got to strike early that
usually is the case if you're ever going
to see an upset but all right before we
talk more about that let's remind
everybody again what does striking early
mean what is the match format uh today's
format uh will be what you know and love
of course it is a 16 player knockout the
players will score points as the clock
ticks down that's the real thing that
makes the SEC so unique and so fun
especially if it is a close match when
you see that clock ticking away but we
will have three time controls Donya of
course 90 minutes of five 60 Minutes of
three and 30 minutes of one your
thoughts on which time control uh gukesh
maybe has the best chance to prove
everybody wrong well I I think you hit
the nail on the head kukesh has to go
off to a good start and that basically
means I think the five plus one those 90
minutes are the most important 90
minutes of the match you dig yourself
into a four or five point hole against
the world champion very likely you're
never going to get out of it I think
ukesh has to shock the entire chest
world of the couple of wins early on
especially given that he doesn't play
all that much online that means the role
of confidence is increased if you're a
perennial online player you don't care
as much about the first couple of games
you know you're capable of winning four
gukesh I think it's so important to set
the tone in the first three or four
games and then to maintain a close match
all the way into the bullet yeah I I
totally agree and also of course not
just for gukesh's confidence to get the
win but if you ever have a chance at
rattling someone who throughout his
career has pretty much been unravelable
you have to do it I think early in this
format um you know we've talked about it
before that the reason Magnus was 9-0
before losing to Maxine vashi the grav
and the semis the last time he played is
because he usually gets out punches his
opponents early and then it's like okay
here comes Magnus Maxine for whatever
reason that day was able to never let
that be the case if gukesh is going to
do anything it has to be early and has
to surprise the world champion uh with
with the a game I guess that he is
bringing to the table all right but
let's talk about the predictions um
they're not going to shock anyone as we
look at what smarter chess uh has has
broken down time control by time control
in this matchup Dania uh that card kind
of speaks for itself it really does and
95 win probability listen I love to make
fun of smarter chess but I have to
begrudgingly admit smarter chess is
called smarter chess for a reason
nobody's taking that name away from from
him and purely on paper a 95 win
probability if anything I think that
that even might be an underestimation
but again you look at that five plus one
score that's the one that where gookesh
really has to defy the odds yep and it's
funny because you know I think that the
the fans first looking in when they see
those scores and those predictions they
might think that seems extreme and in a
single game between two super Grand
Masters that would never be the case but
in a match format it's almost like best
of seven NBA the better team almost
always wins when you have three hours
and that's why you see those predictions
where they are and as you said maybe
it's an underestimation because let's
talk about what the community says is
going to happen more than 14 000 almost
15 000 if we round up last time I did my
math good would say that Magnus Carlson
is going to win this yeah I mean 97
that's a pretty big matchup that's like
Who Wants To Be A Millionaire when you
ask the audience on the 300 question you
better be right if you're if 97 of you
are predicting for the world champion to
win but it's a safe bet
let's settle in let's Buckle our speed
belts the games are about to begin Danny
this is exciting
yeah we see uh we've been watching here
uh Carlson bounced around his room he's
got a lot of chairs um and a lot of
chairs we've been we've been seeing him
mess with his fair play camera for a
while now Magnus was here early bright
and early shower too got his hair did
look at that
um got it he's all ready so wait are you
sure that's showered Magnus or could
that just be I just got out of bed
Madness because that hair that Magnus
hair could be two different things you
know I I know my Magnus hair almost as
well as I know my car Nakamura facial
expressions and that is a showered
Magnus
um I believe ready to rock here gamma
Raju gukesh zoned in looking
professionally wearing that casual
button down ready to put in a good day's
work against the Norwegian world
champion and uh on that note
I think I think we're about to dive in
looking fresh indeed indeed
and and I'm always excited to see what
openings the players bring to the table
we have so many different types of
narratives in the SEC but I'll put all
that aside because the games are off the
world champion with the white pieces
Danny in game one 1d4 I think we're
gonna see a lot of different first moves
by Magnus in this match that's gonna be
no prediction and I agree with you and I
think it's an interesting uh point you
made because I think Magnus is going to
be poking and prodding early you see
experienced players do that because
they're trying to find those cracks in
the armor right where are the angles I
can take against my young opponent who
maybe doesn't have as uh as well-rounded
a repertoire as he will in five years
from now right and so you see
experienced players do that to see if
they can even trick you in a move order
in a transposition where Magnus gets an
advantage uh out of the opening and
there's this idea that people sometimes
carry around that quote-unquote Magnus
is not an openings guy I can yeah I I
can attest that that is not the case
having played my share of Blitz matches
against him yeah sometimes Magnus uh
plays something a little bit offbeat to
get a fresh position but that doesn't
mean he doesn't have tremendous opening
preparation across all of the mainstream
openings and right here we see him going
straight into uh one of the most hotly
contested openings uh in modern Theory
the nimso Indian and opting for a very
solid continuation the Rubinstein
we saw him kind of Shuffle there not
exactly sure what he was uh maybe just
talking to himself about the opening or
frustrated about something but like you
said we have a Rubenstein ooh and wait
it's a mouse slip was that a mouse slip
that's got to be a mouse slip I mean if
this is preparation then I'm gonna be
speechless for the rest of the show
pay for
I don't think we want you speechless for
the rest of the show I'm speaking for
the fans and and the non-fans of myself
so we don't want you speeches but that
is
wow that's interesting I I will say
something something super ominous and
obviously this is super early Donya but
I was the commentator in the 2020 once
speeches Championship where Magnus lost
to Maxime that was last year right um
and I want you to know Donya that match
started with an early Mouse slip by
Magnus Carlson really
and it was it was weird because I
remember me and Robert being like what
is going on here I don't think I've ever
seen Magnus Mouse slip in an SCC and
anyway that day obviously predominus I'm
not saying anything anything like that
happens here but that was um just have
to draw that in I'm having this weird
out of body Deja Vu right now listen you
never know nowadays whether a move is a
mouse slip or not earlier you could be
pretty you could bet pretty safely now I
mean A4 and H4 are just regular
occurrences in basically every opening
but I don't see any justification for
weakening the before square like that
it's quite clear that gukash is flat out
better out of the opening here given his
control over the B4 Square the idea of
playing A3 and B4 is a very important
component of White's plan in these lines
so without it Danny black is holding all
of the cards here in the early going
yeah I agree totally so we'll see if
that uh that throwback or callback to
what happened in that MBL matchup the
only speeches championship match that
Magnus Carlson has ever lost for those
who didn't get that memo
um okay but it's early white is a little
worse but still you're going to get
canceled there's going to be a lot of a
lot of Chess ahead in this game I think
I always I always draw my attention to
the clock
um Dania and just see that gukesh is
keeping Pace at this point with the
world champion that's always a good sign
uh when you're looking at the timer
and Magnus without question over the
last couple of years has gotten a lot
faster he is not an easy guy to face in
time scrambles he might not be as fast
to see Karo obviously nobody is in time
scrambles but it's not like if who cash
manages to get this down to 30 seconds
for both players he's necessarily going
to stand to I bet to benefit I actually
don't think Magnus mines a bunch of
these time scrambles given kukash's
relative lack of experience online but
yeah you can see Magnuson kind of
defense mode going Bishop A6 he wants to
trade the Bishops off I think he's even
happy to get away with the drawing in
game one here
yeah he's uh getting rid of a
potentially dangerous Bishop on the long
diagonal kind of typical of these
positions it sort of transposed from
what was a nimso move order for those
who might be just tuning in Where Have
You Been Magnus is playing Morpheus is
fighting Neo let's go
um but it now now it's a position that
is a little bit a little bit Tamer it
looks kind of like a Queen's Gambit
declined or exchange kind of uh theory
that we might have had here yeah and
good scorers don't win games just
because black holds the B4 Square
doesn't really mean that White's
position collapses gukesh trying to make
the most of his opportunity the Knight
jumping into D3 but I think Magnus
doesn't need to overreact just Rook a to
B1 and then he can kind of nibble around
the edges you could play H3 make some
lufts ah Bishop B1 is a nice move kind
of forcing the trade and Danny you know
if Magnus manages to untangle a little
bit further here he might start playing
for the advantage I mean you have that
C6 Square the idea of Knight back to D4
could be unpleasant the other night
Catalan style can jump into D3
I've seen Magnus win these kinds of
games so many times I mean haven't we
all yeah uh more times than any of his
opponents uh would like to admit um I
agree we're back to a roughly uh 50 50
position and again it is a tame one so
we're not saying dukesh is worse yet but
I like your idea of 1949 C6 Knight D3
and the problem here is what exactly is
is Black's plan to prevent white from
improving right even though that
computer says black has it you know a
microscopic Edge yeah if I'm gookish I'm
like you know what I might even just
simplify this and not let Magnus think
he's gonna play for a win there's just
so many decisions you make just on the
basis of one observation alone and
that's who you're playing I think Bishop
takes he wants to move good cash
probably wouldn't play against most
other Grandmasters but I think it is a
very good practical decision against
Carlson as he activates his own Knight
we might see Knight B5 to D4 we might
see Rook a to C1 but at this point I
think Magnus is breathing a lot easier
than he was after A4 yeah I can't wait
to uh to discuss obviously we'll see who
wins we usually have an interview after
a match and just ask Magnus early if he
did indeed mouse mouse slip that Shout
out to tactics and science tactics and
swindles great name Great Name all right
here we've got a pretty
tactics in this window that's all that's
all I used to do
um but not anymore
um all right man well this looks like a
pretty tame position if white gets B4
though and then B5 and then C6 is an
anchor Outpost square and then A7 is
weak come on Donya give me some
highlights there you go baby I love that
there you go uh Christmas colors there I
want a red though oh there we go red is
the basic color B4 by Magnus and the
Magnus Whisperer strikes again and the
clock situation Danny is up a nice solid
40 seconds
and again I I can't emphasize this
enough gukesh is just not an experienced
online player so it's just so easy to
panic when you get especially below a
minute I think that's the threshold when
relatively inexperienced players
sometimes start to panic online
yep I agree and you can already see the
the eval bar is an evil an eval evil
evil bar if you're gookesh because Here
Comes an edge for white and as
highlighted if B5 occurs and the Knight
pops on C6 even if objectively black
should still be okay from a practical
perspective when you add time under the
clock he's now down by 30 seconds
yeah here comes Magnus and let's not
forget about the move F3 that's a very
nasty move here because the Knight
doesn't have any good squares if it
drops back to D6 that enables the move
Knight C6 and there's all sorts of
tactics there with Knight E7 check I I
attempt number four okay there we go and
Danny if the Knight moves back to G5 you
could toss it back even further with H4
I think Magnus is deciding right now
between F3 or B5 and F3 is on the board
you called it F3 gonna kick the Knight
back to D6 before uh before maybe Knight
C6 happens to me so good question is
going to trade yeah at this point uh
it's at this point it's not necessarily
panic mode but it is Houston we have a
problem let's simplify this thing before
before bad things happen yeah and it's
it's already amazing as early as game
one how Magnus has transformed just a
clearly worse position out of the
opening and not an unbalanced worst
position a worse position with a
symmetrical Pawn structure and now you
would never guess that he Mouse slipped
with A4 on like move five like you would
never be able to tell yeah
but I'm like I have this weird you know
I suffer from Magnus bias itis you know
I never totally know um no totally by
the way Queen D2 threatens or it did
maybe threaten Knight takes a seven
because the Rook would have been
overworked on D7 but Queen G5 hits E3 so
Magnus has to defend that pawn
yeah and you normally don't want to play
F4 here and weaken the E4 Square you
definitely don't want to give too many
prospects to Black Knight but I mean
Magnus might decide on something a
little bit more drastic given gukesh's
time situation you could also see a move
like Rook to C3 if kukash can get the
Rooks off the board I think he would
love to do that uh get done yet I think
White's got these weaknesses I think we
got to show the line you're showing if
we want to bring up the analysis but we
have to Shield this sacrifice coming
from goo cash 94 potentially with Queen
takes E3 check I think we gotta show
that 94 Queen takes D oh no Rook C3
wasn't played Rook C2 was played oh Rook
C2 was played but I think it's this
illustrates the general idea which is
that white can go hunting for the queen
side pawns but E3 is always going to be
a problem but Danny I think the idea of
Rook C2 is an antidote to 94. if you
play it now this looks very imposing but
after King have won there are simply no
checks the rook's defending F2 very
important yeah so Rook C2 does stop not
just Queen F2 made but if the king had
gone to H1 the infamous Venus flytrap
mating pattern so that's what I wanted
to show was that gukesh had an awkward
threat there but okay it doesn't happen
Magnus plays Rook C2 we see in the live
position dukesh has offered a queen
trade no that's the worst thing to do
against Magnus you've got a worse end
game in game one and again look at the
time you've got 30 seconds to defend it
I don't know about this I'm with you and
I I draw attention to the time control
for those just tuning in we got a long a
long format ahead here 90 minutes of
five minutes has just begun we are only
in the first game but gukesh under 20
seconds starts
its own enemy the clock you got two
enemies now the world champion and the
clock and the third is the fact that
you're a pawn Downer to Rook end game
against the world champion I think
Magnus would be playing for a win with
black here I mean when you've got when
you're the one down upon Magnus is just
gonna kind of push his King side pawns
maybe F5 there goes the second Pawn now
lucash is losing this no way I mean
object objectively yeah it's
it's hard to be in a lost Rook ending
against against uh Magnus um but okay
gukesh
he will get white right next game and
that'll be interesting to see what the
youngster brought to the table in
regards to preparation because players
don't hold back
um in this format you know there's a lot
at stake and uh you see Theory happen on
deep levels in the SEC I'm not saying
this game's over yet but I'm saying this
game's over
I think I'm not saying it's over but I'm
saying you're saying you're cut
silver of course Magnus you know he he
screws these up about one time out of
every hundred he's got plenty of time
great time management in the end game oh
now it's over now he's just going after
all the Pawns
nah two seconds for gokesh and he's
simply going to resign what a game by
Magnus that's just like a classic old
school grinded Out World Champion game
right there
yep Magnus of course will now take on
the black pieces as they rematch but no
that was that was why Magnus is uh is
Magnus right we expect this to be a
tough one and uphill battle where
inevitably in the end we will all be
rooting for gukesh if uh if we want we
want to see him keep it close
um but right now you're right that was
vintage Magnus despite the mouse slip
and A4 and despite my call out uh to the
fact that uh when he lost the SEC
matchup versus Maxine Bossier the grav
he also started with a mouse slip but
that didn't happen here today he uh he
wins the first game and we are sitting
here waiting for the next game to begin
so
the storyline beneath the storyline
might be will Magnus repeat A4 just out
of spite you know just to show the
commentators it may have been a mouse
slip originally but hey this actually
kind of works out I mean the greatest
ideas in the world are Generations in
accidental ways
the uh the clock has officially been
paused we see Magnus discussing things
with our team shout out to the team
working super hard there's a lot of
people bringing this to you our
producers are broadcasting but also the
fair play Team the events operations
team
um Magnus obviously having a discussion
with them in some way maybe there's
something going on with the webcam or
with uh or with his second Cam and bye
Magnus love you yeah all these people
delivery is running late
what's going on with magnets though all
right well um you know this game is uh
is a game that how do you get it out of
your head if you're goo cash right the
storyline
telling you is is he shows up he has a
good position out of the opening but it
doesn't matter because as we as we bring
up our insights card and take our first
our first cue to kind of talk a little
more about the storyline I mean magnus's
Magnus is pretty good at everything and
um his Blitz insights while he's played
a lot less games than goukash he's uh
he's pretty good at what he does yeah
what is the strength everything what is
his weakness nothing and that's not an
exaggeration with Carlson so when you're
deciding on a match strategy I mean
everything is relative Danny I mean
you're basically playing into magnus's
strength no matter what you do and
that's obvious I think ukesha's only
chance of the five-minute portion is
actually to take uh a a vast amount of
tactical risk I I really think he's got
to go maybe not crazy with the white
pieces but going for equal positions and
trading queens that ain't gonna cut it
against Magnuson we just saw that in
game one now it's much easier said than
done I don't know how to do that I don't
know how to get Magnus into tactical
positions but you know that's why I'm
commentating
I don't know that anyone knows exactly
how to get Magnus in positions he
doesn't know how to play but you know I
will say this too while while Magnus
hasn't played as many games on on
chess.com as as good cash also played a
lot of games early on
um and really didn't play a lot last
year so I want to give a shout out that
his his strength and accuracy is
probably even better than it shows
because he hasn't played a lot of a lot
of online Blitz over the last year until
the last couple days to kind of try to
get in good form against the world
champion so
um you know it'll be interesting to see
but as as we saw it is a matchup that uh
that is a tough one for gukesh because
even when Magnus is worse out of the
opening
he can come back right and so what do
you do if you're ghukesh and you're
psychologically trying to shake that off
well I think to borrow a phrase I don't
always like uh you got to lean into it
and you got to remember that at the end
of the day and this is this is something
I try to remind myself of when I get uh
you know the great opportunity to play
Magnuson just a casual Blitz match hey
you're playing the world champion right
there there are worse ways than starting
off a day or finishing off a day in
gukasha's case then facing off the world
champion in a match obviously nobody's
necessarily expecting you to win but
that's kind of a good thing every single
win against Magnus is a huge occasion an
occasion to celebrate and I think that's
how gukesh should approach this match as
just a general learning experience
rather than overthinking the final
result if that makes sense it does it
does um and it means that we're going to
be you know doing the instructive thing
where we're talking about the
instructive moments and maybe not
necessarily uh how how equal the score
is depending on where this match goes
but you know I've watched a lot of
baseball I know what it's like to
commentate when a score gets away from
from one team
um anyway we see magnus's insights there
I I don't know who put together the
insights card but his inside strength is
everything
um and I like that I don't know if that
was a troll but it's it's kind of true
um so yeah we're waiting for Magnus to
uh to fix some of his Tech fix some of
his uh whatever's going on there how
many world champions does it take
etc etc you know how many world
champions does it take to uh to organize
organize a webcam we need we need to
have an assistant there um to to make
sure we can actually see his fair play
Team behind him which I love um right
there on the chair High Fair High fair
play Cam and fair play Team um when he's
on camera we'll talk about that so
anyway
we uh we see the SEC matchup record you
know we might as well even talk a little
bit about what that means I know that
Magnus is probably not thinking about
his loss to Maxime uh to MBL right now
but I will say this
I think as this event goes on assuming
Magnus Carlson uh does deliver on what
we expect him to do and move on I think
that that matchup will be will be
something he's thinking about and I know
for sure because the last time he and I
talked about it one of the first things
he said was that he loves the SEC format
and he knows that he lost the last time
he played in it and he wants to write
that ship no it's it's eating at him no
matter how many you know what the number
is going to be in the win column the
fact that the number in the Lost column
is anything other than zero is going to
eat at someone whose expectation for
himself is literal Perfection you know
nobody in the history of Chess uh
arguably accepts Kasparov maybe Bobby
Fischer has had the kind of record uh of
elite chess the Magnus as over the last
uh decade plus so again his standards
for himself are so wildly out of the
realm of the normal that anytime there's
a one in the Lost column in any
tournament he's going to be disappointed
and he's going to try to wash it away
with you know endless more wins yep well
we'll see what good cash can wash away
again I think psychologically that is
one of the hardest parts of playing
Magnus in a Mac is that even when you
have a game where you were better if you
don't convert it just it eats at you
right where you go like well this is
kind of hopeless but like you said focus
on the positive and lean into it right
like there's a few video YouTube videos
online where I played Magnus in some
random Blitz and all I ever remember
from that is that I drew one game I
don't tell people that there are six
other videos after that where I lost
every game right
exactly what videos are there just the
first one um right so anyway here we
have an Italian the first move on that
note switching to E4 from D4 and a
symmetrical Italian until Magnus uses
the H6 variation ooh and castles early
we could get a sharp one with white
Community castles that means yeah
exactly
now the one of the ideas of putting the
Knight on C3 is is to meet G5 with an
early Knight D5 kind of striking at the
center white could go Knight D5 here
anyway white could play this in
traditional style with Bishop E3 which
gupcash does and you know just a
relatively unambitious opening setup by
by the Indian Grandmaster just just sort
of a regular Italian position so popular
these days let's let's talk a little bit
about that that G5 it didn't happen but
you know that's that's kind of a modern
way that black can look to spice things
up if you are in a Muslim situation
right white castling early in Black
playing H6 not just to prevent Bishop G5
but to play G5 that's not happening here
but that is an idea we might see later
on in this match if they keep playing
this position yeah we might even see the
move G5 with the king castle kingside
that the fact that the king is on G8
doesn't always preclude black from
pushing G5 especially if you could
ensure that a knight appears on G6 and a
queen appears on F6 shortly thereafter
Knight D5 by gukesh so normally Black's
reaction here is to take on D5 and then
to meet Bishop takes D5 Danny with this
97 Knight G6 maneuver of a Magnus taking
a little bit of time maybe he's thinking
about Bishop B6 to keep the tension
okay and this is definitely Theory uh
for those looking to improve their
repertoire or map anything out this is a
symmetrical Italian kind of four nights
idea but but there's a lot more than
meets the eye that's why Magnus is
pausing you want to make sure he gets he
gets the right shuffling in here uh to
be to be fair and I think that gukesh we
asked the question Dania what will he
have prepared for this match what do you
bring uh to the battlefield when you're
when you're prepping for a world
champion it might be an Italian I like
his position right now so far after
after the first 10 or so moves yeah and
gukash has been so impressive in the
opening phase in his last couple
classical tournaments of course none of
us will ever forget his performance in
the previous Olympiad Fabiano
caruana-esque you know kind of a
repetition of that sink-filled cup I
think he started eight out of eight and
only lost the next game by miracle that
was amazing and and that really put
kukesh on on many players is Radars I'm
a little bit surprised that Magnus took
on E3 which is oftentimes times a
concession when The Rook is on F1 aiming
at the F7 Pawn but Carlson decides I
think that they're just not enough minor
pieces here for white to really whip
anything up on the king side okay
reasonable
yeah makes sense normally in these
positions with the file open white can
slide with Queen E1 and over to that
side of the board but like you said with
pieces being traded both the Knight and
Bishop unlikely white is really
mustering up something scary on the king
side is that what you're saying asking
for a friend that is but I would play
Queen E1 anyway I I like this idea
Queenie won Queen G3 and then maybe
Knight H4 Knight F5 which you often see
in these lines two by Gucci kind of
taking the more Slow Roll approach
asking Magnus you know what he wants to
do with this bishop on D5 we could see
Bishop takes D5 at any moment but I
think White's gonna take back with the c
pawn and maybe even start playing on the
queen side with a uh an attack against
that C7 Pawn which is going to be a
backward Pawn uh in the event of the
trade I was gonna say on that note what
is what is Black's strategy are you are
you thinking about taking D5 or were you
trying to get white to Blink first some
maneuver where you move the knight from
C6 in order to play C6 yourself and
force white to capture on E6 what is
what is Black's planer obviously moving
the night might lose the B7 Pawn so
again asking for a friend teach me what
you know about this position normally
I'd say the idea is to get white to
Flinch first here I would seriously
contemplate taking on D5 and that's
because of the presence of the B4 Square
Magnus goes Knight before immediately I
thought about this but I didn't see
exactly what the idea is in response to
Bishop takes B7 and then back to D5
because if we pull up an analysis board
Danny really quickly yeah and I think
okay should take on B7 the idea is that
you can't well maybe you can try Bishop
D7 with the idea I was yeah I was
worried about it
I'm just gonna say there's no sacrifice
on F7 what do you mean there's no
sacrifice computer I hate you it's good
for black me too you just drop it back
and you stare at your opponent in the
face and you say you have no follow-up
here you have to this is what Magnus oh
my gosh this is what Magnus has already
looked at we see in the live position
right below our cameras here the gukesh
hasn't taken yet but here he does take
on B7 he goes for it no but Magnus
doesn't go for Bishop B7 he decides it
is just a pure Pawn sacrifice no and
it's and that's not a good thing for
Magna he doesn't have enough
compensation I mean yeah the Knight is
sitting pretty on before but kind of a
strange sequence of decisions for the
world champion he takes a lot of time
and this is a big chance for kukash in
the early going Danny I don't want to
overstate the case here but you've got
to try to deliver if you're white no I I
don't think we're going to be
overstating the case at all throughout
the whole day if we're saying this is a
big moment for gukesh because he might
not get many you've got to take him
right you don't swing at the king and
Miss as they say
um and so I I agree I mean you can't
miss with an opportunity where you've
won upon Magnus obviously has some
compensation on the B file maybe we
should highlight that as well as the
beach upon being backward
you know and here he comes with the
swing to double the Rooks makes sense
but but if you're goo cash I think I'm
gonna give one piece of random advice
into the universe he won't be able to
hear me but I think the main thing is
you can't overthink this down here what
we often see here is now he's going to
try to be perfect and convert and get
himself under time pressure and somehow
Magnus wins his black we see people do
that against Hikaru and Magnus I think
you got to trust yourself and try to
play quickly not trying to be too
precise because it is Blitz agree
completely he's been doing that so far I
love the way gukesh is handling this so
far Rook ac1 uh mysterious looking move
but the idea is an antidote to D5 in the
event of D5 you take it and then your
Rook sits on a lovely open file now
gukesh says hey I don't care about the
pressure on the B file I'm going to
Checkmate you on the king side maybe
even a move like Rook F3 and pile up
those pieces while Black's pieces are
scattered about the queen side
I I agree totally and I think that that
might be to me if I was given the
Practical advice bird on the shoulder
that's what you go for Donya because you
have to take your chances when you get
them and and you you can't be afraid to
go all in right because you may not get
another opportunity here he goes I love
this queen of two queen G3 let's go on
the king side whoa that is a sacrifice
Magnus doesn't take on D3
I thought Rook F3 might have been a more
precise way to start Magnus follows up
with G6 and his cash is going to leave
the Knight on F5 that is a common
sacrifice in these Italian positions for
now he goes Queen G3 pinning the g-pawn
and is Magnus gonna duck away onto H7
but what about Knight takes D3 we're
gonna have to bring back the analysis
board but just to show the obvious lines
because this this game is about to get
tricky so if black plays Knight takes D3
white has what I think just from cd1
okay and D6 is hanging in the end and
you could play Rook B3 here but then you
lose lose sight of the F7 Pawn this gets
really nasty for black yeah so Magnus
you see is indeed by King H7 yeah
stopping Knight H6 and maybe renewing
eventual threats spicy stuff by kukashi
just says Hey Magnus take my knight
you're gonna get ladder checkmated I
love that move if you take gf5 Rook F5
Here Comes Checkmate on the edge of the
board this is the kind of game if you're
writing up the storybook upset you know
Rudy takes down Notre Dame or what
happened in that movie did he go to
Notre Dame or did he beat Notre Dame any
Hooters okay so if you're writing the
Rudy story it starts with this type of
Chess By dukesh I know he went to Notre
Dame calm down calm down everybody no
that's a fantastic move and Danny it's
not just a defensive move he's preparing
to blast open the center with the move
d4 and that pawn on D6 that Queen on d8
Magnus is falling apart at the seams
here and he's got 45 seconds let's see
how this guy follows this up
gonna say that's the other thing that
you get excited about is on the clock
I love this move d4 I love that you have
to put pressure Magnus is maybe going to
be under 30 seconds here in just a
moment
yeah but this is the champion but this
is where the world champion is so
resilient he just does not die it
doesn't matter how much time he has on
his clock he's gonna make ukesh work for
it and I love how googkesh is just
keeping his Knight on F5 it can never be
captured as long as the queen sits on G3
cutting off the king
I love it I love it we asked the
question when we were viewing the
insights there what does gukesh do to
get Magnus in tactical positions that's
a type of position gukesh might want
this is the kind of game you're looking
for this is this is exactly what you
need Magnus now under 20 seconds where's
the beef gookish you gotta deliver yeah
where is that crushing blow Magnus is
still pretty solid on the king side
gukesh continues to pile up his pieces
doubling on the file 10 seconds now for
the world champion and Danny I mean d
takes C5 and queens oh no there's got to
be a knockout here I think just night
age gotta be a knockout no 966 is Knight
takes D6 an option
Queen takes D6
Rook takes F7 there's also just move the
Knight anywhere like even H4 because if
the queen goes to E6 then you can play
D5 and keep the pressure
is there a move like C5
is the best I think you're calling it I
think C5 is totally crushing Danny
because then you play D take C5 and put
the Knight on D6 I think C5 ends I mean
fine he goes for it gukesh finds it
seven seconds for the champ oh and he's
all in now he's like well might as well
take now H5 Rook G5 one zero it's over
it's over oh my lands what a game
gukesh says not so fast go and brush
your shoulder off youngster it's a match
baby not so fast everyone
yeah and Magnus I mean his body language
kind of indicates frustration yeah what
a comeback win for guccesh
that was amazing and and he got exactly
the type of position he needed to get
exactly the type of position a sharp
Italian with attacks on either side of
the board Danny and he played with
nerves of Steel he had a minute left at
the end of the game so impressive
I'm I'm absolutely I'm absolutely not
necessarily blown away because I I
believe that gukesh can do this oh my
gosh is this going to be the most
exciting draw Ever the most remember
John do we commentated on the no it's
not the most this is Berlin I've never
seen this before there's a rookie oh my
God look at the position the pawn
symmetrical the pawns are symmetrical
but have you ever seen a rook on E5 on
move nine this is amazing oh it's not
like you're on E5 I've never seen a rook
on E5 I've seen an elephant fly though
and this is a symmetrical Pawn structure
where everybody's equal
wow I just I can't get over that game
was so impressive but here's the thing
Danny if you're a gukesh unfortunately
you're gonna have to repeat that for
another three hours
but still he's got something to hang his
hat on even if the match doesn't go his
way that was an amazing game that was an
amazing game clip it and ship it
damaraju gukash strikes back says this
will not be a runaway he's already half
a point away from equaling smarter
chess's prediction in the five minute
time control you got to give him that
and I mean seriously I know I know we
know this is an upper battle we know
that we're going to be adding drama so
fans forgive us for that but the reality
is if we're talking about a storyline
which is our job to try to predict what
does gukesh have to do with his style
what does he have to do to lure the
world champion into some sort of Deep
Dark Forest where he loses his way it
has to be great preparation Donya which
he had in the Italian tactical positions
as the insights showed and then you have
to deliver when it matters under time
pressure and that's what gookesh did so
again obviously it's early but that's
the kind of game you want to see if
you're hoping for a close match yeah and
you want to catch Magnus in those casual
moments you know Magnus doesn't seem too
concerned he's snacking it's still so
early in the match I mean nothing has
happened yet but but again it's all
about the confidence booster right if
you're gukesh hey I can beat the world
champion I can outplay him and I didn't
just benefit let's say from a mouse slip
I outplayed him fair and square that
game you gotta carry that confidence
forward for the rest of the match and
right here we've got a really
interesting position Danny Magnus is
down upon but he's kind of buried the
bishop on C8 under a pile of rubble how
is kukesh gonna get his Queen side out
well this is a typical kind of thematic
sacrifice we see for white in these
Berlin's now maybe talk about that for
the for the more advanced astute fans
out there to talk about the Dynamics
because we see white doing this in this
variation Berlin taking taking the
opportunity to add dysfunction to the
queen side in exchange for the pawn
um and what exactly does black need to
do you have to get B6 and Bishop B7 but
when you do there's tactics like Queen
E4 you highlighted it before I can save
it we're completing each other's
sandwiches
[Laughter]
you see I learned any I learned Robert
Robert has just got so jealous wherever
he's sitting he just got so jealous
um anyway so yeah exactly that this is a
difficult spot for black um and that's
what that's what Magnus is trying to go
for and uh the bishop pair
notwithstanding um white does have have
the edge here yeah what best repair
bishop and he did that
one reason only in order to be able to
play B6 uh you called it there was Queen
E4 uh on the immediate B6 no black is
worse here there's no question about it
white can basically win the pawn back on
demand if white suddenly gets the
hankering to restore material equality
you can go Rook D1 and queen D3 and
whatnot but I think Magnus is going to
go for more and Magnus could still play
against the bishop with a move like
Bishop D5 and then C4 black will develop
to A6 but that doesn't solve all his
problems I was just gonna I was just
gonna ask for a friend and suggest
Bishop d55 I love that move here comes
C4 like you said the bishop remains in a
cage what you really want if you're
Magnus is to somehow get the Rook to E1
right if rookie one wasn't met with
Queen takes E1 background Checkmate that
would be overwhelming the lady on E7
because look at the queen and Bishop
ganging up on the F7 Pawn that's exactly
uh what what black has to worry about so
if you're Magnus how do you create
pressure against that Queen on E7 so you
can do work with the attack
yeah that's the right question to ask
you basically need to open up a second
front I think the long-term plan for
Magnus is first to play C4 make some
left on the king side so you don't have
the headache of the back rank mate and
then try to get the Rook around maybe
via D4 either to E4 or it's F4 and as
you said gang up on that F7 Pawn gang up
on Black's Queen
I don't know how go cash is going to
deal with that he plays A5 I would be
very worried about just like H3 and Rook
D1 and that's very magnetic Magnus style
as well
yeah Magnus taking a moment to ensure it
I think the one thing is if we bring up
the analysis board the one thing black
has is that Bishop A6 if it's met by C4
black will strike with B5 right and
that's the move that opens up the Rook
on B8 and tries to get some counter
plays so if ace3 Bishop A6 C4 B5 black
is getting that play and there is still
no rookie one because it's check so
again I'm I'm just an international
Master sitting in for a Grand Master
friend but this looks like you can see
black is starting to come to life here
so that's that's why Magnus is pausing
this isn't just a cakewalk at this point
yeah no you bring up a great point and
one idea very much up magnus's alley
would be to play C4 Bishop A6 and then
A4 precisely to prevent B5 and to open
up a pathway for The Rook to E3 so you
know you're doing a bunch of things at
once and I don't even have to make these
moves on the analysis board it's on the
real board
yeah A4 first yep and there we go and
now he goes C4 so you were right that it
was it was going to be on the main board
soon
um just like we're going to see a lot of
cash paid out reminder for the fans just
tuning in we got 18 000 plus of you
already on Twitch I guess people like
watching the world champion play rising
stars from India I don't know they
didn't show up for me okay they probably
showed up for you but I think they
showed up for the world champion and for
the rising star from India welcome to
the SCC we got a long day ahead so as a
spawn structure for black Black's got a
long day ahead in this end game oh gosh
this is like one of those I feel like I
was given an example as a kid uh by some
you know Russian trainer I had that said
let's imagine the worst Pawn structure
black could ever have in the universe
and then they set up a position pretty
similar to this you know isolated Pawn
on H7 highlight with me Donya doubled
isolated f-pawns double isolated d-pawns
this is these are pollens only a mother
could love these are I like it and
you're never gonna go B5 ever as long as
you're alive so Magnus just has a heart
blonde share on the king side you can go
Rook D3 D4 whatever H3 F3 literally put
the Rook on any file and it's gonna be
good I just threw up in the back of my
throat a little bit if you don't mind
I'm gonna grab some of my really cold
coffee that's been sitting here that's
been for like weeks
Bishop B7 though I like how go Kesh is
approaching this thus far get the
Bishops off the board first that's step
one and Danny you're probably gonna have
to give up at least one of your pawns if
you're good cash but you are up a pawn
technically I know it sounds crazy wait
is that am i counting correctly it's
hard to count black spawns it it is hard
to count because they're that bad but
let's also draw attention that Magnus
Magnus wasn't happy about whether he
missed Bishop B7 or not he definitely
believes that the dismaneuver of the
bishop not being on stuck on A6 now on
C6 is an improvement for good cash I
think based on his reaction and the
evobar believes that as well and and
gukesh he's not just sitting back and
being passive Rook G8 inducing the move
G3 and I think he's activating his Rook
via G5 there we go and Danny if Magnus
throws an H4 that looks like a no risk
kind of move but guess what that stops
your Rook from coming up to H4 yep and
H7 becomes relatively invulnerable well
I was going to highlight the same thing
on F4 F4 also looks like a no-brainer
move but if the Rook if the Rook backs
up you've also cut off your Rook swing
over although if things Rook H5 here and
white plays H4 that Rook is running out
of square so I think you have to be a
little careful now if you're googesh
it's yeah Magnus gonna play F5 okay no
not anymore goes in for Rook H5 but I
wondered if the Rook backed up whether
we'd see F5 so no I think we might still
might see F5 Magnus is going to take
back with a pawn unless he I mean Rook
takes D5 is a draw for I I think the
pawn end game wait is it does the king
run D3 C4 B5 okay no it's a draw you're
right you're right you're right okay
it's actually not not that
straightforward though you're right
because the King has these two different
pathways on both sides of the board
Magnus was thinking about it he takes to
the pawn okay and now I think he's gonna
make a Mad Dash for B5 but kukesh says
hey I can just go Rook H6 Rook G6
on G3 The Rook will fall back to D3 this
scene to me this seems like a big
Improvement if white is King D3 Rook H6
King C4 Rook G6
white gets there in time is this really
what dukesh wanted oh yeah that actually
can get really hairy so maybe after King
D3 you should prioritize getting your
king to B7 maybe that's the Fortress and
then Magnus is gonna try to infiltrate
the e-file yeah there's there's some
meat on the bone here for sure
when you say Fortress I hear magnus's
quote he doesn't exactly and no and no
Fortress he's a flat earther when it
comes to fortresses am I allowed to say
that is that politically correct anyway
moving on
um
we we don't have a fortress if you're a
Magnus fan
um I don't know so before also is a move
hmm
I don't know 58 seconds though Carlson
taking a long thing here I think he's
trying to decide whether it's even worth
making an attempt because you could risk
turning this game around you're still
down a pawn
okay he he goes for I think Magnus will
will risk it
he likes those biscuits here it comes I
actually really like your point of B4
wait I think B okay it's not B4 now now
it's the line we were talking about
there must be something concrete
similar to The Rook switching to the E
file like you already highlighted and
what go cash forgot about it he had to
get his King to beat B7 now Rook C4
rifle in these end games it's crazy and
he takes a sip of that iskar water shout
out to magnus's sponsors is like a
little that's a confident Swig we always
say what is the psychology you only
drink water when you're winning or happy
is that what your buddy Peter G says
that's exactly what he says and I think
that's wildly accurate like 99 of the
time is you don't feel like drinking
water if you're losing and it's over
Rook C3 next wow you're losing both of
your queen side pawns oh that is a
heartbreaker there Danny after such a
good defensive effort let's let's let
this next game start if we can quickly
show the fans I think for a lot of
people where that ends is a little bit
like you feel like you're uh you're
you're worried where's where's the
where's the food right I'll feed you
baby birds let's bring up an analysis
board but we can and show why that
position was so lost because after King
B8 I think white has to find a really
really subtle Rook C3 Donya to show
exactly why black is completely busted
so that's exactly I'm gonna pull it up
here yeah
um okay
see there we go so yeah you might say
hey black is up upon in the final
position but as you're pointing out
Danny after the king drops back we can
bring up an out yeah Rook Rook C3 you
ain't increasing the pressure on this
pawn and White's just gonna collect
these two pawns and and I think it's
important to show it's important to show
this because it's not every day black
resigns in a rook ending up a pawn let
that sink in white plate Rook C4 check
and black resigns in a rook ending up a
pawn and so I think showing this is
really instructive this move Rook C3
guard C3 and the house crumbles
there you go and just really quickly
before we move on the actual mistake for
Google Castro is this move Rook H6 wrong
priorities he had to go King d8 King C7
and just in time you reach B7 and on the
next move you work on your Rook but he
can be forgiven that's hard to figure
out you know at the drop of a hat with
less than a minute against the crack
against the Carlson
well here good cash will now get the
white pieces again as we focus our
attention once more on game four hey
knock on the door Rhyme Time all day
welcome to the SCC it's the main event
as we said 16 players are in a knockout
uh they're moving on for big prizes of
course if we get a tiebreaker ultimately
we have one plus one for four games and
then Armageddon if you missed you missed
a roni in winning an Armageddon you
haven't been watching the most exciting
event since sudden death dodgeball and
that's the SEC yeah go back and watch it
but only after this match because plenty
of entertainment left Magnus back to a
one-point lead and a very kind of
you know gritty positional battle here
in this rosalima with both players
pushing their pawns on either side
Magnus trying to drive the pawn up to A4
Danny I think to restrict the mobility
of this Knight and prevent Knight B3 so
maybe go cash should play the smooth
while he still can
it's funny I I always struggle in these
positions as black as a sicilian player
when You Face a rosalimo because it just
feels like it's only a matter of time
before there's doubled C pawns are the
focus of the game it's like being on the
white side of a nimsa right so help me
understand what tension what Dynamics is
black trying to keep so that now because
B3 there's going to be Bishop A3 and at
some point white is going to have to why
Black's gonna play Rook C1 and then if
there's threats of C takes D5 where C5
is hanging black has to do something or
those doubled C pawns become the focus
yeah and I'll preface by saying that I I
don't play the E6 wrestling with black
precisely because these structures are
really really challenging and I think
purely objectively White's probably
better but Black's got some things going
for him on the other side of the board
first of all this Pawn chain uh is is
very very strong it's restricting the
Knight on F3 you've got the bishop pair
and at some point in the future if you
can get your Knights somehow to F4
that's going to be a huge game changer
because then you're going to be able to
apply pressure on D3 of course that's
easier said than done and that's
precisely why gukesh got his Pawn to H5
I think a lot of people are like oh he's
attacking no the pawn on a tribe is
fulfilling a purely defensive role so
you sometimes actually see black pushing
G5 to try to induce on poisson instead
Magnus taking the alternate route I
don't know exactly where he's going
though Danny yeah if I'm go cash I'm
just going Bishop A3 and I'm saying hey
what's your plan and again I played the
Ninja for my entire career as black and
this is a similar structure you see
where white has parted black has parted
ways with the bishop Aaron and nimso in
order to get these long-term weaknesses
and here comes Bishop A3 as we said Rook
to C1 will at some point be on the board
whether you take right away or not on D5
white has this constant threat of cash
again and that might Force black to play
D4 exactly but if D4 comes white can
continue to maneuver and eventually try
to capitalize against these double pawns
but maybe D4 ultimately is forced and at
the very least white doesn't have a
clear way to bring another attacker
right ooh I'm surprised I thought D4 is
is at this point kind of a no-brainer
and now he plays it okay yeah he waited
for go cash to put his Rook on CEO
because now The Rook kind of just looks
dumb but I think the eval board was
revealing that gukesh maybe missed a
chance to take D5 I I wonder if I mean
because now the D4 has been played Black
is actually back in control so again for
those who played this opening or maybe
some of our more advanced audience you
can back up and look at that I think
there's a lot of a lot of theory a lot
more subtlety there than maybe first
meets the eye and Magnus didn't hesitate
to play D4 instantly when he had the
second chance and I think the nature of
gukesh's a misevaluation he thinks that
by playing D4 black is kind of untying
White's hands for action on the king
side the problem is black is the one
who's in charge on the king side even
though white has more space right now
and why does the more obvious Maneuvers
black will eventually let Queen D7
castles and eventually black is going to
have ideas of F5 and ideas of Bishop G4
so let's see who ultimately takes charge
on the king side that's where the battle
is going to shift starting now I would
play Knight H4 without delay if I'm
Googling
9h4 before we even think about
re-maneuvering the Knight on D2 yeah
have they forgot about castling Mr
Chunky it's a funny question but to be
to be real about it you might not only
not see castling it's possible you see
black tuck the King on on C7 even on the
other side of the board and then
completely shift everybody to a King
side expansion I see Don use eyebrows
raising despite that early in the
morning I know I know you like what I'm
what I'm preaching here I totally like
entropriate we're speaking the same
language here eating the same sandwiches
I think both Kings might find their way
to the queen side but Danny if white
brings his his King to C1 that pawn on
B3 isn't entirely safe I mean there
could be a sacrifice we're talking like
way down the line right now but that's
what you got to do when the center is
closed you're switching from concrete
calculation to more conceptual reasoning
because it's hard to calculate
concretely there's just so many
candidate moves on every move and I
think that's reflected in their time
usage
agreed uh you should see one still a lot
of pieces on the board for the time that
is ticking away for these players I I
kind of like the idea as you're
highlighting of bringing the bishop to
D2
but Nelson on that note Danny Carlson
striking Magnus listening to my ideas
he's always listening to my ideas he's
gonna put the King on C7 and then he's
gonna try to advance on the king side
um
he might go King C8 also to keep contact
between the queen and the pawn sorry go
ahead
oh look at this he's going to bring the
Knight to B4 which blocks The Bishop's
Gaze on the a pawn that's a timely
little maneuver there from that Pony
making like a luka doncic Euro Step you
know that when you do the Euro Step in
the NBA it's basically moving like a
knight I thought about that the other
day
kind of in a nail shape I can see that
you're doing two steps that looks like a
travel probably is a travel but now that
they haven't called it for 10 years they
can't start now you know what I'm
talking about the Euro stuff
well they only call it when Steph Curry
does it but not when Luca dunches
the worst whistle in the NBA but anyways
uh wow are you literally gonna say Steph
Curry is the worst voice on the end oh
my gosh how many championships do you
have before you can complain he's one my
son spiders whistle
All Right Moving On Moving On
um all right Bishop F7 that allows a
diagonal a double take on G6 though
isn't their tattoo you can't chew in a
pawn
let's show it to the Batcave we go
analysis board HG HG Knight G6 Bishop G6
Queen G4 baby girl oh wait wait what
yeah I just okay no it's still good for
white yeah yeah just to show that the
Knight on H1 doesn't impact the
mechanism did Magnus Overlook that and
Danny this is where something you said
is so important I think ukesh has to do
this quickly you gotta not overthink it
and just trust yeah Magnus missed this
tactic don't drop yourself down to 20
seconds before you do it anyway yep and
he's gone Queen G4 first
uh that's a big difference because now
if you take on G6 maybe black has Rook
G8
or queen G I was thinking Rook G8 but
Queen G8 okay either I think big missed
opportunity there go Kesh is gonna won a
pawn now I think Magnus could go Queen
G8 anyway and this is just a paper tiger
I mean you don't have any way to
increase the pr or or this you can never
take on G6 anymore and this is exactly
what you're saying I think that I think
that in hindsight when young players
look at those opportunities again and
maybe that's why a guy with more
experience like MBL was the only person
ever to oust Magnus from the SEC because
he's played Magnus enough where he's
like look I know you're better than me
but if you blunder I'm not gonna be
afraid to call your your BS so to speak
right I think young players
second guess and that was that was a
clear tactic that we all saw very
quickly and gukesh misses a chance to
cash in and it'll probably bite him uh
if Magnus comes back and wins this game
although I do really really like his
last move F4 Fearless play on the king
side and Magnus meets him at the top
with F5 and we're about to see some
major fireworks on the king side she
takes eight H5 is his idea and then I
think he's gonna take on F4 obviously
the queen is hanging so you can't take
the Knight
wow wild stuff Knight takes F4 this
position is about to blow open but who's
who's better than this I know the email
bar is sitting there saying oh White's
still going to be better but from a
practical point of view I mean about
called you Magnus Am I Wrong to start
feeling more nervous for white that
Queen on d8 Spies The Knight on H4 that
King on E1 is completely naked there the
emperor has no clothes yeah I'm much
more nervous to be white here than I am
to be black despite what the the uh the
engine is saying totally and and cash
has to trade as many pieces as possible
because positionally black is worse that
Bishop on F7 is a granite biter it's
biting on granite on one side and on the
others Alva Bishop takes C4 is a
potential tactic in some cases because
the Rook on B2 is undefended so I think
objectively it's probably about balanced
and cash has gotten this into a Time
scramble Rook to E3 Oh What A Move by
Magnus an exact replaces The Exchange
the evil Bar says White's better but I'm
looking at that pressure this is where
blunders happen you ever wondering the
bumper sticker blunders happen
blunders happen right here when you've
got your king in the middle of the board
but kukesh keeping his composure giving
up the pawn on B3 and Danny his idea was
to prevent the Bishops traveling to D4
white is now objectively much better I
don't see enough compensation here
for the world should be surprising
surprising if Magnus didn't have a
concrete follow-up that's not totally
his style yeah I think uh Rook B1 maybe
oh he goes for the queen trade I was
taken for rookie three
do it oh he doesn't he plays Knight F3
but taking in Rook G rookie three was
good no even so now the Queens come off
there's two past Pawns in the middle of
the board let's go E5 no but guke should
have taken with a rook on e4 he gave up
that pawn on C4 and he let the bishops
get active and now Bishop E3 and Bishop
D3
yeah but Bishop E3 is winning too
short K1 Rook a one
I'm surprised Magnus missed it what in
the world just happened there
oh my God
it most certainly was it most certainly
was okay just you know when when I when
I'm seeing mates on the board you have
to be like Danny you're crazy or I mean
okay definitely not crazy
we see It ultimately we do see It
ultimately go referrals this way he wins
he wins that game has a two-game lead to
start the first half here of our 5-1
portion
and I've got to catch my breath John you
take it away oh my God that I'm still
processing what just happened there
Magnus with the unsound exchange sack
hukesh refuted it perfectly Danny and I
thought he was going to win when the
Queens are about to get get traded I
think his mistake there was to trade
Queens in the wrong version he let
magnus's bishops get too active and I
think the main concrete mistake was
remember when he he recaptured the queen
with his d-pawn that let the light
squared Bishop get active and that was
the reason Magnus didn't have enough
comp in the first place is because his
light squared Bishop was bad once they
got active things got very difficult
from a practical standpoint a hard
breaker for the Indian Prodigy there
completely agree Magnus is eating a
banana does that mean it's banana time
for all of us
I don't I just put Magnus put more than
half a banana in his mouth right there
that was um
I was a banana time for all of it we're
all doing it oh my God you just you just
like unfurled you're just Uncorked a
random banana that you just had next to
you I always have bananas around here
page Magnus says it's snack time if
Magnus eats a banana everyone eats a
banana hey everybody at home go get
yourselves a banana good potassium great
for you thank you that pulls out a
dragon fruit do you have that nearby too
you don't know what I have in the studio
let's just say it's a bag of tricks not
more than not more than Beth Harmon wigs
hanging around here um all right so we
have another Berlin a different move
order than what we saw in game two if
you're or it was game three
no yes it was game three the second time
Magnus had white if you're just tuning
in Magnus started the match with D4
switched to a Berlin in game three and
now uh in game five we see another
Berlin for the world champion I like to
keep track of the storyline of what the
openings are kind of tells us maybe
sometimes what we're gonna see Donya as
the time controls get faster we said
Magnus would try different things he
would poke around we've seen D4 and E4
played
yeah and I actually think this is a huge
game because in the blink of an eye it's
now a two-point lead that was a that was
a two-point swing right there gukesh
wins the game it's still a tied match
he I mean a draw here would go a very
long way towards stabilizing things
going into the halftime break of the
five minute portion a loss and and the
train you know the Magnus train will
start to leave the station
talk about how hard that is as a player
you play chess at a pretty high level in
your career Donnie I don't know if you
knew that you're pretty good at chess
how hard is it it always sounds easier
said than done to say stop the bleeding
right that's the phrase we were both
given by our Soviet trainers you don't
want to lose more than a couple games in
a row but psychologically
you want to win when you're down two
games so how hard is that to gather
yourselves make the make the discipline
decision which is your black and you
need a draw despite being down two games
just focus on what's in front of you
it's super hard and again I I want to be
more sparing in my sports references but
I really think this is a good analogy
you see basketball teams when they get
down
um the less disciplined teams just start
jacking up really bad shots they start
shooting three-pointers
um and they don't run their plays
because they're trying to do everything
at once and it's so easy to try to do
the same thing in chess the other
problem Danny is in a Swiss tournament
when you lose a game you normally get an
easier opponent the hardest tournaments
to come back from are matches and
tournaments like the US Championship
where you lose a game against onus Shook
and you're getting karanakamura on the
last round right here exclusive game
against Magnus Carlson and in the next
round you get Magnus Carlson and after
that you get Magnus Carlson again hey
who do you get after that I
that might be the case yeah you're right
it's the definition of out of The Frying
Pan into the fire right playing a match
against against someone like Magnus
Carlsen and so you know it is it is
something that I think chess players
it's one of the last muscles chess
players really develop which is that
kind of emotional discipline putting the
prophylaxis kind of the smart unbiased
decisions ahead of ahead of what you
want to do as a human but you're right I
think gukash getting a draw here heading
into the halftime break as we call it
for the first 90 minutes of the five
minute portion probably the smartest
thing he can do doesn't want to go down
three games
yeah
again but he's in trouble yep
he's just flat out and look at this
position the Knight is pinned if you
have to take on D2 White's Bishop is so
strong in the open board Bishop C3
Bishop takes G7 as a threat
yeah this is nasty
yeah the Knight can't move because the
queen on D7 is hanging for those for
those wondering what the pin is there
and and that's a problem because Bishop
C3 is coming also H4 H5 is on the agenda
where you start to see white mounting
pressure from both the king side pieces
and the queen side pieces is when you
when you have a problem and that's
you know there's more than meets the eye
in a symmetrical Pawn structure we kept
talking about why gukesh was playing for
a draw maybe we were taking for granted
that that's because you flee to Berlin
and and that is a position where usually
black has decent holding chances but
this is not the kind of Berlin you want
white has all the pressure
and gukash has a minute 20. I don't know
how he's meeting Bishop C3 Magnus
holding that move in reserve instead
he's lifting The Rook up to F4 and of
course if you have to play the move G6
and I think ukesh will that means you
know you you create this massive gash on
the king side that white can occupy with
this queen but now okay Magnus just goes
for the E file very positional approach
here
I love that what a switch right there
it's the only open file on the board
which means whoever dominates it will
get access to all the other things that
matter this is such an interesting
switch from Magnus giving up the pin
because rookie Ford was also possible
and there was no rookie eight for black
white could trade and win the night but
I really like his awareness that the
e-file is now the most important thing
to control uh and that's what Carlson
goes for and I would contemplate going
back to G4 now that there's a massive
outpost on E6 for The Rook so Queen G4
and rookie 6 looks really pretty gukesh
of course wants King F7 and Rook E8 and
if he can get those two moves then you
know that's the danger of hanging your
hat on an open file if that file is
taken away from you your advantage kind
of evaporates and the bishop ain't too
happy all of a sudden it's kind of
staring at a bunch of Black's pawns so
so Fargo catch defending pretty well
there's funny I I was gonna ask whether
G4 was possible there for Magnus because
the Knight didn't have any other squares
besides H6 you could trade shake and
bake and Mom helped with Queen E7 right
I mean there was an idea there where
okay he doesn't go for it but whenever
there's only one open file I always told
my students for years that open files
are like Commodities and that supply and
demand are the principle that govern
them and so there's only one it's more
valuable so that e-file that Magnus is
controlling is going to be the way for
him to either and he goes G4 so I was
again now there is Queen E7 at some
point yeah there's also Bishop H6
so Bishop H so rookie eight is kind of a
semi threat right now it's not a real
threat as long as the Rook is protected
by the bishop maybe bishop C3 is a good
compromise move Magnus shifts his Queen
to D4 that's proful oh that's such a
nasty move to face Danny because now you
can't play rookie eight because the pawn
hangs and you could play F5 here but I
would never open up the long diagonal
for White's Bishop so gukesh just kind
of has to hang tight here and try to
find the right opportunity to go rookie
8 which he's trying to do on the next
move maybe rookie three and Rook F3 to
keep the Rooks on the board is what the
doctor ordered here for Magnus
yeah and I'm still not sure he shouldn't
have played Queen E7 I mean I'm not just
doubling down on my Commodities
reference of supply and demand I I don't
know that White's Advantage is any
bigger here than it was earlier but
still hard to see how that night
improves and that pawn on G4 we always
say a knight three squares away from a
pawn is nominated we meaning Robert Hess
the Royal we see those Pullins those
pawns dominating that Knight on G7 make
it really hard for black I'm actually
Loki surprised Magnus didn't try to keep
the Rooks on the board now I think
kukesh I mean his position is still very
nasty Magnus still has long-term ideas
on both sides but at least black can
play quickly and black and rattle off a
bunch of these moves Queen E7 King F7
and the margin of victory has has
narrowed considerably I think magnus's
idea Danny is maybe to go C4 and B4 and
A5 and ultimately to Target the C7 Pawn
actually
let's see yeah I agree although I I was
just sitting here
mentally thinking about the fact that I
also agreed with you that Magnus trading
Brooks didn't really feel like a way to
improve the advantage and the open file
has no longer is no longer a storyline
in the position Black's Queen owns it so
so I like dukesh's changes if we had to
say this position versus what it was 10
moves ago black has a much better chance
to draw I think from here but I still I
would still choose Magnus here there's
another idea which is to play C3 and B4
pretty common in these ideas opposing an
ultimatum either you trade and allow the
outside passer not an option the Knight
is terrible at stopping Corner pawns or
you allow white to take on A5 and create
a long-term weakness that's on a dark
Square kukash defending very well though
H5 trying to create weaknesses that he
can attack on magnus's King side to
deflect his attention from the queen
side
I like it a lot and Magnus has to be
careful if you missed out oh yeah you
bring the king up is black striking with
things like F5 you create or and the
Knight starts to get into those squares
so yep I'm
you know white is still in the driver's
seat but if if gukesh opens up the king
side it would even be worth let's say an
imaginary Pawn because if he can get a
draw get a Perpetual check against the
white king over there that doesn't have
defense this is this is what gupesh
needs and the time pressure is starting
to become real here yeah Magnus trying
to be as flexible as possible he brings
the king up to defend G4 I'm just
worried that Magnus is going to find
some way to complicate the game and
gukesh with 17 seconds for the rest of
the game
again we've seen Magnus win so many of
these games in so many different ways I
think F5 and queen E6 check in response
to Knight G7 is very strong
he goes Queen E1 that's interesting he's
flipping the script to the king side
threatens Queen H4 oh but that was such
a beautiful tactic I think you take it
I'm pretty sure you trade and then you
go to C5 to restrict black snide
completely
I think your move F5 was better than
magnus's Queen E1 I agree but if you
take and play G5 I love where that
Bishop on C3
starts to flex on the night we always
say Bishops are better than Knights when
you have pollens on both sides of the
board we see the bishop dominant if you
can open up that A1 h8 diagonal okay so
Magnus keeps the Queens on the board but
but now he's got problems with this D5
pawn and if you have to go King before
Danny what you mentioned earlier F5
check maybe I mean it opens up the
bishop no now he gives up D5 but
now he's lost what's going on here he
just gave up the most important Pawn
with check he's running the king to the
queen side oh and it's it's still a
three result game
just don't take G5 because Queen h8 is a
mating problem
um now he's pinned himself
But Here Comes C5 and D4 but but the
bishop Bishop slips in through the
cracks and C7 is now a huge oh no he
maxes oh my gosh I think Magnus is
infiltrated Here Comes Queen H7 no he
switched to the queen side instead oh
don't get checkmated on G7 just just
shuffle your king don't make yourself go
cash he goes for 57 but he's gonna lose
a bunch of his pawns on the queen side
he's gonna the king of five and the
bishop is blocked the g-pawn's running
who's fast but the a pawn the a pawn is
so much faster the a pawn is faster the
email bar is evil
I'll answer your question Danny the a
pawn is faster sir oh my God
oh my gosh and with that Magnus Carlson
as the infamous Meme and video reminds
us too weak too slow is how most of his
opponents have felt throughout his
career and in the time scramble Carlson
gets it done
not the prettiest win but you know just
like the exchange sack the game before
Donya we've seen a Madness who's willing
to take risks here just to put new cash
under practical pressure and even after
a Magnus blundered his most important
Pawn he wasn't even thinking about
trying to bail out clam off and make a
draw he was still playing for a win that
entire time and just the pressure that
he puts in time scrambles is
unbelievable what did gukesh in
ultimately Danny of course is the
futility of his Knight and the fact that
he had those weaknesses on the light
squares and something which was not
pointed out enough is that it's
incredibly hard to time scramble when
you've got long-term weaknesses when
you've got something you can never do
like trade Queens practical difficulty
of that cannot be overstated great
effort by gukesh great effort wasn't
quite enough he's down by three
well we saw the great effort ultimately
not be enough just as you said he is
down four to one unfortunately for the
goo cash fans out there the smarter
chess predictions are proving correct
and we're seeing a Magnus Carlson who's
willing to take risks in order to get
those dubs uh he he hasn't been dominant
but he's converted when it mattered most
as you said it's hard to play positions
under time pressure it's hard to play
Magnus Carlsen uh but uh but it's it's
not hard to uh to watch the uh the
speech has Championship we got a uh we
gotta we gotta we got a a break to take
I'm sorry we've got a break to take I
lost my way there we're gonna continue
of course with the back half of the last
45 minutes for the the 90 seconds of 5-1
when we returned the SCC is right back
at you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
hello
welcome welcome back to welcome back to
the speed Chess Championship we are
watching gookesh the pensive expression
on gukesha's face as he stares down the
barrel of a three-point deficit halfway
through the five minute portion
let's remind everybody of our community
predictions 97 of you
predicted Magnus Carlson the world
champion
to win the match and so far that is
aging pretty well
but the good news for gukash is that all
of the games thus far have been really
really close
and virtually all of them have gone down
to a Time scramble
so I think it's important for gukesh to
kind of extract the positive out of the
match so far but as usual Magnus Carlson
has been an absolute buzzsaw
it's been a pleasure commentating this
round of 16 match for you alongside
International Master Danny wrench we've
got 40 minutes or so of five plus one
action and then there will be an hour of
three plus one followed by 30 minutes of
one plus one
all right and here we see Magnus Carlson
he's put his hoodie on
Danny resolving a couple of audio issues
here I think I can hear you now Danny
perfect I can hear you
I can hear you perfectly Danny
I can I can hear you guys
awesome
and we are ready for the games to begin
Danny
I'm here uh I can't see anything
oh I think the games the game hasn't
started just yet
okay
we're waiting on Magnus there he's put
his hood on I don't know if that's a
good sign or a bad sign
um
I think we're back to
back to muting Danny
no but he's smiling
wait Danny you can you can hear me right
all right
still waiting on Magnus here
is arms are crossed
all right I think you can hear me now
Danny
awesome The World Is Right indeed I
missed you dearly Danny I don't know how
I survived these last two minutes
honestly it was it was a heart-rending
moment heart-wrenching moment
you got got what I did there right
spell it with an SCH just like this guy
I know
no comment Let's uh let's talk about
that let's talk about that oh
oh
how could I have
I'm slipping you're you are you are
slipping but it's okay I'll take it all
right we've got um
we've got a Carol con uh an advanced
Carol with the bishop outside the
structure for those uh looking for the
defining Factor here Black's Bishop is
not back there on C8 where it's blocked
by the closed Center so these positions
black has solved that huge problem
but white has some chances a little bit
extra time and sometimes that Bishop can
even be a Target which is why black
plays H6 to be able to bring it back to
H7
yeah and Lucas's setup is called the
short variation this is probably not
even arguably this is the topical way to
meet the uh the bishop F5 Cairo uh in
the last couple of years and it's a very
positional line so the battle is going
to revolve around both sides of the
board black will often play C5 French
style Danny and then the knight from E7
moves into C6 it's like a French or the
bishop outside the ponchian I don't know
why anybody would ever play the move one
E6 again after seeing this position can
we just turn this into an infomercial
for why you never play the French look
how happy that Bishop is on F5 highlight
highlight it for me Don you're making it
make it green baby because it's happy
green is for good that Bishop is happy
it's got a diagonal it's got a it's got
a safe Square on H7 I mean tuck away
spot yeah who plays the French am I
right
you're preaching to the choir here I I
it's totally beyond me
well all right uh Jokes Aside we have a
position that uh black is striving for
C5 as Donya highlighted you see the
queen on B6 the night on D7 the pieces
will coordinate to try to get that play
um but white is a teeny bit better um
despite black solving the bishop
problems that's usually because the
computer is kind of like the space that
white has and uh the the opponent E5
giving white a little more Luft but
what's the plan here if you're the first
player
it I just want to maybe not exactly
answering the question I think a lot of
people are wondering why not C5 what's
the hesitation so if we bring up an
analysis board really quickly and this
is part of Gucci's plan is to play
against C5 what often happens if you
play C5 prematurely is that there is a
big trade on C5 white can stick a bishop
on this really nice Outpost and then
follow up with Knight D4 Danny and then
the bishop slides into E3 and the queen
gets in trouble so with the King side
still undeveloped playing C5 often
contains a lot more risk than benefit
and that's why we see Magnus taking a
fundamentally different approach he
moves his Knight away to G6 and that
clears the space for the bishop to come
out to E7 but kukesh shoving his H Pawn
right down the board and liking the
Knight back to f8 or maybe to H4 he
likes that h-pone push we saw him do it
in the uh in the other in the other game
that he had as white and then Ross and
limo so so like in that little H you
know Harry Harry you're a wizard there
that H1 Knight H4 though by Magnus which
is a good lesson I think that when you
have less space if there's a safe way to
trade minor pieces as long as it
tactically works this is usually the
preferred approach and that's a good
lesson for any any viewers out there
looking to learn from Magnus putting a
knight on f8 not what you want here you
want to get some pieces traded to give
you give you some more squares and your
pieces aren't wrestling each other
anymore
and I always struggle in these positions
with white because the evil bar always
gives you know something between 0.5 and
1.3 here it's giving an entire point
which is a bit supposedly a big
Advantage but how do you follow up space
advantages don't win games you actually
have to convert it into something
tangible and often that's something
Danny is F4 G4 and F5 but I would be
very nervous pushing those King side
pawns against the world champion yeah
especially because once you push them
they can't go back right thanks Captain
Obvious but pawns don't move backwards
and opening your king will often come
back to bite you especially in fast time
controls right even if it's something
you would do Donya In classical chess
Blitz is just a different animal where
you know that inevitably
okay Knight D3 is going to allow Bishop
E4 and G2 is a problem and if F3 then
Bishop takes D3 Knight takes E5 is so
easy to miss it's a tactic it's on the
board will Magnus see it
Bishop E4 nasty little move white can
play G3 there but there would still have
been Knight F3 Bishop okay so Magnus
instead goes C5 uh wants to start
opening up lines
pretty surprised actually that Magnus
didn't go Bishop E4
yeah he maybe maybe didn't see the
tactic as possible
he goes instead for the mass trade on C5
and now that he's castled kingside you
don't have to worry about Bishop B5 or
Bishop B3 all of those moves are totally
innocuous so I still think black has
solved all of his opening problems here
yeah
agreed
and uh
the issue is as these pieces are traded
I'm feeling more and more like white
didn't get enough out of the first stage
because e the e-port is a little weak I
guess you can play Bishop E3 Bishop D4
right if you if you can anchor in a
bishop you're not stressed about it
maybe you do have F4 and G4 still on the
agenda
um okay wow Bishop F4
and another reason the Caro is such a
good opening for Blitz is that you often
have all of Black's pieces on perfect
squares and you have that here the
bishop is so nice on H7 it's just
slicing through the entire board kind of
ruining the coordination between White's
pieces the Rooks can come to d8 and C8
and the Knight can always swing back to
F5 to prepare the D4 Pawn Break by the
way very unpleasant idea or it can exert
more pressure on G2 without
aforementioned Bishop E4 move which uh
hasn't gone anywhere and is still very
much possible I was gonna say that's
still possible although G3 now a little
more interesting than before because if
Bishop E4 G3 that Knight might have to
go to F5 and is your Bishop getting in
trouble on e4 so
um I really like the instructor point
you you had about black pushing D4
because I think that's a thematic one
for people to understand about the
structure because you don't really want
white putting a piece on D4 and that's
called a wedge in a structure where you
replace the middle Pawn with a piece if
black can get a rook on d8 and play D4
usually the tactics and and the space
that is opening up there we'll prefer
we'll be preferred by black
yeah and as one Robert Hess would point
out as Bishop E4 is in fact on the board
black holds the main Pawn break and
black has a second Pawn break in F7 F6
which you do see in the French often
yeah uh and it can also get very
unpleasant look at White's King side
pawns they're both weak and again it's
the Magnus effect you just don't want to
play a move like G3 against Carlson so
that's going to be additional time cool
cash goes G4 G4 laps in my face he says
hey I don't want to play G3 I want to
push it one square further G4 here we go
not quite G5 and we live quite G5 and we
live for Canty but damn girl G4
um it's it by the way I know that I know
the eval bar said yeah that's okay for
black but I kind of like the spirit I
like Teenage two coming next to unpin
the F Pawn maybe I can play Bishop E3
and F4 go back to the idea you said
there's also Bishop G3 as a threat in
this exact position where's that Knight
going Donia yeah that's the twist we
thought the bishop was gonna get in
trouble now the the night's in some
trouble but F5 by Magnus he just says
hey I'm meeting you at the top and very
important Bishop G3 here the queen can
drop back to E7 Defender Knight and they
can also adopt an attacking posture
later from G5 I don't like the direction
that I admire gokesha's bravery to play
G4 but I feel like in the context of a
Blitz game Danny he's got way too many
weaknesses on the king side
yeah I tend to agree and again it's it
is a little bit of the Magnus biased
itis right he's playing the world
champion we know what he does you know
the position is very tactical and
unclear in some ways but every second
that ticks off the clock the harder it
becomes to play positions where your
king is open you are more likely to
blunder this is a fact and so yep it's
why we were nervous about these ideas
despite the initial Applause to G4 and
let's go we saw Anita in chat but but
I'm very nervous about White's position
yeah me too Bishop to E3 so good cash
knocks the queen out of C5 and paves the
way for either F3 or F4 depending on
where Magnus puts his Queen F3 does
technically trap the bishop by the way
so but but there's gonna be two four G4
what is going by the way the computer
lovely sacks the he goes full braunstein
baby it's a clearance sacrifice pieces
and Bishop H1 is an idea that light
squares are just you know massive holes
F3 here then Magnus will play F takes G4
using the knight in the queen to
generate an Unstoppable main thread on
G2 this is amazing dude D4 can we bring
up the analysis board to provide a
little bit of instruction on that move
d4 because I'm also wondering whether
dukesh should have bailed and taken with
the queen Donya could he get into the
end game he should have right because
you're gonna get mated otherwise but the
thing is here Magnus could have dropped
his Queen back okay six with the same
types of threads so apparently the move
was Bishop takes E4 Queen C6 and now F4
with the idea of meeting Bishop H1 with
Rook F2 how do you miss that with 30
seconds such an easy idea very natural
recapturous but okay there's moves
happening who cash played Rook C1 no but
this is total I mean look at the light
squares on the king side oh my gosh this
is this is uh Sue and queen F3 is coming
opposite colored Bishops are invading a
lot like your in-laws over the holiday
season you didn't invite them they show
up they're dominating the holiday season
and you're like how did you get here I'm
sorry in-law reference I blacked out a
little bit Danny look at this queen is
going to H4 it's over look at that
maneuver we missed it
it was made black
it was your dominant the obstacle
Bishops are but Magnus has now missed
forced mate in a couple games so despite
him leading the match crazy
is just basic Betty right there look at
this winning look at this still winning
the light Square problems remain your
in-laws haven't left yet this is the
problem when you have an attack to
defend on one color square and your dark
Square Bishop is like a big Pawn there
on E3 let's highlight it in red look at
that big Pawn on E3 doing nothing man
here comes 93 and you won't have any
more pawns left after Magnus finishes
taking all of them go cash is gonna flag
on top of everything else
one second then Magnus is going to
promote his Pawn H3 HP H blood H2
your wizard Harry you always why can't I
do that I'm missing mate in like three
and still winning in like three moves
like that that's the margin of victory
that Magnus Carlson has and that's
because he dominates all of the squares
positionally total positional domination
leads to scenarios where you can miss
mate and still be completely winning yep
yeah if you're just tuning in to Magnus
missed a force made in a previous game
uh again also still one and here he
misses queen d8 queen H4 but also still
wins right but it is an instructive
lesson of obstacle Bishops and the
problems they're in your Bishop was
basically a bystander on the dark
squares if you're gukash Magnus shows uh
how to convert those things and he's got
a four game lead to go with it man and
it's weird because the games are pretty
close the middle games are complicated I
wouldn't say that he's blowing gukesh
out of the water yeah in any of these
games he's just getting the upper hand
uh in critical moments I mean he's just
outplaying him from dynamically balanced
middle games and that's maybe even more
impressive really we both said the same
thing and it's it's not to necessarily
disparage Magnus but he hasn't been that
impressive today honestly but I think in
the time scrambles he's just been that
much sharper has a little more
experience I think than uh gukesh does
and uh it kind of sucks to say that if
you're gukesh because Magnus maybe
hasn't even found his form yet Stella
hasn't even gotten her groove back yet
and she's up for games
but that's what makes you know athletes
like Magnus so impressive you know when
when somebody at that level has an
All-Star performance anybody can come up
with a dominant Victory the real
question is how do you play when you're
in mediocre form can you still dominate
even when you're missing a lot of stuff
you normally would see yeah the answer
thus far has been a resounding yes but
the match is very far from over we still
have two more segments and a four-point
lead it's not a 10-point lead bukash can
still you know one Victory and we're
seeing a different tune yep you've got
it you've got to uh start somewhere what
do they say one game at a time focus on
what you can control how many sports
cliches can we fit in it is what it is
right you know it is what it is do what
you can here this is a game just down
the stretch all the things right last
game of the year Dan canceled anything
back now
um anyway this effort but okay but all
right you get you get it the point is
kukash he does have a pretty decent
position here as black I mean I know the
eval bar favors white a little bit but
this is this is a certainly inflatable
one the problem is we called it forward
a couple games ago and I'm gonna call
for it again he needs to stop the
bleeding he needs to get another point
on the board if you're just tuning in
first of all where have you been you
cash won the second game in in fine
fashion by the way it was an awesome
game and it and the score was tied 1-1
but Magnus has been on a tear ever since
and I think if you're ghukesh forget
about the score hold play a great game
get a draw against the champ and then
you can build on that
yeah you just need to not lose and once
again I'm worried just giving magnus's
body language as he kind of sits back
his hoodie is on he's in Sinister Magnus
mode right now
and that Bishop on D5 is such a monster
and it's going to be replaced by monster
even if you capture it which I hate
about pieces like that you take it
Magnus might even take with the e-pawn
Danny and organize some serious pressure
on this E5 Pawn so Magnus preparing A4
A5 on the queen side yep protected past
pawns are a problem and we see it now
the pawn on C4 protects the D5 Pawn for
those who don't speak chess terminology
yeah that's called a projected passer
Here Comes A5 prying open another file
for The Rook on B1 this is a position
that Magnus has uh he's massaged a few
of these before toward a victory and
this is this is a tough one for black
dukesh has to has to create counter play
on the king side and he's got to do it
in short order because Magnus is already
you know the enemies are at the gate on
the queen side so maybe a move like
Queen F6 to prepare for and
simultaneously protect B6 now white
could be the one to play F4 there so you
know let's not forget that the E5 Pawn
is also a weakness
yeah and look at the clock Magnus
playing with so much confidence in this
game I was gonna say I mean I want to
play like H5 if I'm black and sacrifice
the B Pawn to get H4 you you have to do
things that are more practical in nature
I think if you're gonna mix it up while
you're getting round down uh but uh he
goes E4 and I think Max is just gonna
win the beep on I think he's gonna
Magnus is totally not buying this yeah
he's going to take on B6 twice and he'll
take back on D3 after the Rooks are
exchanged and the protected pass deep on
um you know Daryl Daryl's gonna run up
the board touchdown on d8 and gukash is
trying to you know stir things up on the
king side the issue is that he's
basically out of pieces I think Magnus
could even just play D take C4 oh I
guess the idea for gukesh is after a
takes B6 maybe at some point there's
like Queen C7 forking the two pawns or I
thought it was maybe E3 I think which is
why I would take 24. okay
yeah which E3 happens you're
at least you're giving yourself a chance
right you're saying there's a chance
no there definitely is a chance of black
plays E3 maybe even G takes F4 is is a
move here because you know you're King
on G1 is perfectly safe black again is
out of pieces to attack with Magnus is
spoiled for Choice here he plays Rook
takes E4 also possible
yeah getting pieces off the board makes
sense when your king is about to be
opened up makes you feel a little more
safe
Magnus now has two pass Pawns in the
center the E and D pawns for good
measure
oh man
what now we be
can we see seven not right away right
Pawn takes uh obviously yeah first you
take first you take it Rook B6 Queen C7
that's a fork
oh there's Queen B3 there
so I get oh Rook B6 maybe there's Queen
C3 one of those types of moves could be
really nasty for white yeah Magnus you
know that f file is open but he's so
good at squeezing I was gonna say these
types of positions I was gonna I don't
know that Magnus will do this because he
he squeezes these positions well uh not
quite engine light but as close as any
human probably is
but let's not let's not underestimate
that this is a blunderable position for
Magnus that's the point is that that
open keying the openf file this is a
position where that eval bar could swing
on a single move if Magnus isn't careful
no question about it which is why he
puts his Queen on the most solid Square
on the board where it simultaneously
protects C4 protects this important F3
Square the F2 score and to add insult to
injury for kukesh E5 is now a massive
threat which might necessitate a passive
move like rookie eight yeah well then
white micro FDF file right we talk about
open file Commodities supply and demand
you give up the file is white just gonna
switch Rook F1
and uh yeah or or the B Pawn yeah
I don't see it here or go cash
I don't see it maybe Rook F3 I don't
know
yeah actually Rook F3 doesn't look too
bad he just resides oh wow just resigns
to start to strike back I mean
on the one hand I respect the match
awareness one of the things that we
often see preventing people from making
comebacks in the speech has Championship
everyone is playing lost positions
probably longer than you should because
you're also competing against that enemy
above our heads there in the sidebar
which is that counting down clock
and if you're going to mount a comeback
you have to do it within the time frame
right it's a shot clock if you will and
so I mean Don again he's playing Magnus
I don't think that this is the beginning
of a comeback for gukesh I'm just
pointing out that there is some
practical awareness of the fact that
like look yeah I could lose this game
now or I could lose this game in
literally four minutes from now right if
I continue to defend this horrible
position so let's go for it and I I
respect that
yeah it's just that you don't quite feel
as dejected against anybody when you've
got a bad position against Magnus when
you start losing a lot of games
consecutively like the moment you're
slightly worse you already feel like
there's literally no hope you feel like
you're playing an engine and I
personally don't get this feeling really
against anybody but Magnus it's it's
just a unique sensation of utter
hopelessness and in the blink of an eye
he's up by Five Points smarter chess is
sipping some dumper and yawn somewhere
in some dark whatever somewhere whatever
smarter just no one even likes you
anymore exactly
shout out to smarter just shout out to
the whole crew bringing you the SCC
shout out to the fair play Team say hi
to magnus's little chair there you see
that little phone on the chair that's
the fair play camera observing his field
of vision of course there are a lot of
other things going into that uh but uh
but just you know high high fair play
Team hi love you miss you bye
um
they like our MBA references Dania I see
uh Chad really taken kindly to American
Sports references
yeah
ukesh
kind of mixing things up here one D4
and Magnus at this point just kind of
playing chill mode BOGO Indian you know
just get in close positions and
squeezing them out into victories
Yep this uh interesting structure you
have a
a maroxy bind style structure for white
with E4 and C4 cramping down on D5 and
B5 uh black actually has a boloslavsky
hole position which is not a not a uh
not a traditional maroxy bind or like
you would see in a sicilian with the
e-pawn being traded you see this
position from BOGO Indians and Kings
Indians did I just hear Ebola slavsky
reference I didn't hear inch I'm
impressed you did hey Pawn structures
101 baby you ever seen that video series
on chess.com Pawn structure 101. I wake
up it's my alarm clock actually it might
it might have helped you before you
wrote your positional chess books you
know
um if if only I'd known it just feels
like Magnus is already better here it's
so weird yeah like from a conceptual
standpoint anytime there's a Marazzi
bind White's supposed to have an
objective Edge but the way magnus's
positioned his pieces is Rooks coming to
E8 the knights dropping into C5 there's
a hole on B3 you know Magnus could
secure it with A4 it it's the Magnus
effect again you always just give them
the benefit of the doubt these
complicated middle games it's crazy
yep
yep and uh despite the space
disadvantage for black Black's pieces
have squares and that's usually kind of
a key indicator you can have lack of
space and your pieces are wrestling or
you can have a position like this you've
got the Black Knight maybe has C5 uh the
the darksword bishop on F6 is
comfortable you can even play G6 if you
want to keep it on that diagonal to Back
That Thing Up The Rook on E8 hits the E4
Pawn so latch position is
it's just fine
good cash going aggressive with F2 F4
the drawback is that now you've got the
long-term weakness of the E4 Pawn but
the plus side is that in some positions
E5 can be a tactical idea opening up the
light squared Bishop so Magnus can't
fully fall asleep on that idea yeah
black could trade everything on D4 and
go Queen F6 I feel like that's the kind
of idea which is up magnus's alley yeah
simplify remember the thing that happens
to space as the pieces can no longer use
it if you don't use it you lose it
literally with space which is that the
the squares become weaknesses and they
become holes and they become targets and
so if you play imaginary chess and just
do what Don you just did there take all
the pieces off at D4 Queens come to F6
and they're traded those dark squares on
D4 and even E3 are weak the F4 Pawn
looking it starts to look more over
extended rather than strong and this is
an important kind of instructive measure
a lot of people can take in their games
if you're worse and you have less Space
Trading can kind of turn that space your
opponent has into some open air for for
for you to attack
yeah that's a great point and of course
it takes the sting out of these tactical
ideas like E5 yep and Magnus taking a
pretty deep thinking they're going to go
straight and queen F6 takes the skin out
of the position just as you said takes
this thing out of E5 takes this thing
out of White's white space
now if I'm good cash I would actually go
for the trade and then go 93 and try to
stick the Knight on D5 ASAP before black
is completed as development using the
fact that E4 is Untouchable we can bring
up internet well okay actually not
because he goes for it I think he's
gonna go I like it a lot and by the way
let's bring up the analysis board anyway
though because after 93 after 93 let's
show why Knight takes E4 doesn't work
Knight to D5 and Bob's your uncle with a
double attack on C7 and the Knight on e4
there you go look at that you were
moving the pieces right as I was saying
I I just I feel so at home with you it's
also at home with you I feel so safe
it's hard for me to not be in control of
the mouse it's been my whole life but I
feel safe with you Dania uh well I have
big shoes to fill in regard my arrow
drawing is a lot less accurate than than
yours I will give you that
but you know I really dislike Gucci's
move A4 I don't get that at all because
you know the medicine is worse than the
disease here you're assuring
the problem of black going A4 but you're
creating just massive weaknesses on C5
and B4 more dark squares you can't
afford that agree and now you can't well
you can still go Knight E3 Maybe
but at that point already Knight takes
C4 is on the table
he goes rookie three yeah I mean the
eval bar also agreed I think you were
right you were right on the money that
93 was needed and timely now now you're
you're defending the epon if anything
but this is this is a bit of a Magnus
effect right it's hard you miss
opportunities because you're not looking
for them you maybe play as you said the
Cure is worse than the disease you play
a little more defensive than you should
and
um black as black has solved all of his
problems here
yeah and you just you just slip into
defensive mode automatically even if
you're slightly better you just assume
you're slightly worse because you're
playing Magnus and go cash with G4 so
he's still trying to uh to build up some
activity on the king side yeah obviously
with the Queen's off the board as a
paper tiger and one typical idea is for
black to later play G5 and carve out
this massive outpost on E5 yeah for one
of his pieces so you might see Magnus
going h60 goes G6 though to stop Knight
F5
yeah I really liked your G5 idea of
course it didn't work there because
white would have played Knight F5 but
but it is it is a good one but here you
see again it's less space for black but
show me a bad piece for black the bishop
and Knight are doing what they're
supposed to do the Rooks are doing what
they're supposed to do this is how you
maneuver and play positions with less
space and uh
and like you said whites what does that
phrase use paper tiger on the king side
the big Pawn's face Tiger Tiger yep
paper tiger indeed and Magnus you just
know he's gonna save her every moment of
this end game he just this is this is
his Jam right here
and his jelly
jam and his jelly
I'm pretty jelly of his end game
technique I'm just gonna ignore that I
could take it I could take this so many
different directions here but um all
right H4 is played it is it is a it is a
Crouching Tiger even if it is a paper
one right he's trying to pounce
create some kind of Playmate seven
that's an interesting movie he's kind of
inducing F5 and then he'll probably just
go right back to trying to use the E5
square of white plays F5 yeah you
highlighted it and um and if if G5 he
can go Knight back to E6 at some point
again trying to okay you can see him
chipping away chipping away and 96 is
going to be unpleasant later because if
there's a trade on G5 Danny then the
move F5 permanently weakens the g-pawn
mm-hmm
though we keep talking about stopping
the bleeding maybe the the you know the
practicals I was just going to say the
Practical thing to do is just King F2
and do I just like sit and say all right
I'm just taking a draw like I'm just
gonna play King of two King F3 and what
do you got here rookie two rookie three
maybe that's the prudent thing to do
it is and you've got to do it fast he's
taking 15 seconds per move you cannot
afford to drop to 20 seconds here and
defend this for another 70 Moves so yeah
I'm very pessimistic about kukash's
chances maybe try to trade everything
with F5 or maybe even H5 but that
requires calculation and boom he's down
to 30 seconds already
this is why they play the game time is
time is part of it and uh he's taking
another 15 seconds on this move and
Counting
when it goes red
when the clock goes red fine you gotta
hurry up
and you just know Magnus is going to
find some way to mix things up here you
don't see it right now everything seems
to be protected for why Magnus gonna
find the right time to go 96 and Knight
D4 and he's gonna jump around and he's
gonna win one of White's Pawns
and he's doing it inducing these pawns
forward saying come and get me big fella
every Pawn you push can't go back
becomes a weakness there's a blunder
Knight D3 He blundered Knight D3 winning
the exchange four don't tell me Magnus
is gonna miss it whoa he did walk down
he misses it Magnus is is missing
tactics today it's crazy but he again
he's still winning he's like the same
narrative repeating itself over and over
again he's so positionally dominant
Danny that he can afford to miss this
stuff and still win
it's good to be king
Bishop E8 I can't believe in this Knight
T3 that was like what's funny is Bishop
F7 is almost zigzbong uh down let's
highlight the bishop on D1 has to guard
both V3 and H5 yes he's stuck
yeah but the good thing for why this is
what saving ukesh King H4 there's H6 and
the pawn slips in
aha taste the soup where's the spoon oh
but there's the Bible City Pawn Victory
B3
goodbye no this is everything's
collapsing here yeah A4 Falls F5 will
fight we'll fall next and we will likely
get one more game in the five minute
portion here if you're just tuning in
maybe watching the SEC for the first
time it's 90 minutes of action of five
minute Blitz before we move into the
faster time controls that follow three
minute and eventually bullet uh we will
get one more five minute game I'm sure
after this I don't think this is gonna
take another three minutes for Magnus
yeah
it's gonna take another 10 seconds the
bishop can come back to G8 anytime H6
happens I would just push A4 I think
Magnus might be trying to bleed the
match clock but I don't think so
it's interesting Magnus also very aware
of the meta strategy that is that
ticking clock you see above magnus's
camera two and a half minutes
two minutes and 45 seconds
there's no way he prolongs this game
that long though you can take G4 and
then take H6 okay no he doesn't
that was gonna flag yeah
oh just another clinical Magnus display
right there just vintage vintage Magnus
game yep
vintage Magnus game vintage Magnus
hoodie he likes to be all snuggled up
when he's winning himself some chess
games you know get him his blankie
he already took a bite of his banana
we're back to that name so by the way
proving a form was a mouse live we see
it if you're just tuning in Magnus
played A4 in that position in game one
which we speculated was a mouse slip of
course
yeah and we're gonna have to confirm it
with him in the interview of course
assuming that we interview him
can't make any assumptions it's still
still plenty of Chess left to be played
but he has gone full circle here in the
final game in the five minute portion
full circle back to 1d4 which is what he
played in game one
uh the scoreboard slightly more dominant
than it was uh in game one a six-game
believe for the world champion
um winning streak six game winning
streak it was tied one to one it was
tied one to one
it's crazy how this is all unfolded and
who can I mean adoption is on the table
if Magnus can win this one
we don't like to use that word around
here as a guy who's been adopting more
times than he'd like to admit
hey I've been adopted so more times than
I'd like to I was talking about real
life but that's why I'm in therapy you
know lots of bouncing around for this
guy different discussion
um but okay also also on the chessboard
I'm making me all emotional
it's okay later later we'll virtual hug
it out
um
a nimzo here uh for black I like Lucas's
position I know that the edge for white
is there on the email bar but these
positions are playable for black you
just you gotta get Bishop B7 in before
white starts pushing E4 oh wait it's
white to move here
wait it is way to move and E4 is a
possibility E4 is a possibility
in the attack Center
okay now white is better here no I mean
white is clearly better I was looking at
the position thinking black plays Bishop
B7 and it's all good I play these Nims
oppositions but but no it was white to
move I don't get why white has gotten
this move and I actually think Queen C7
is a very serious Mistake by gukesh you
have to go Bishop B7 here yeah and at
least make it hard for white to go E4
and I wouldn't say that this is tilt but
I just feel like kukesh is dejected and
he's giving magnets everything he wants
out of the opening in every game
I I agree and it's funny everyone can
see that like the way that whole thing
went down in real time was like very
revealing of what's happened like I was
just assuming because you have to give
Bishop E7 in those positions you have to
stop E4
Queen C7 was a mistake tiltus is the
strong word to use but it's probably
probably a a very real thing here
and this is a great position for white
this is what you don't want as a ninja
which is the position starts to open up
what are you giving up in the nimso
everyone the bishop pair meaning that
dark Square Bishop is literally this is
not a paper tiger this is a Crouching
Tiger Hidden Dragon it's coming to G5
and the attack will be on black has to
get Queen side pressure before white
starts expanding the space and using the
bishop pair but that's not the case in
this game
I was thinking about a wild idea if we
could bring up the analysis board as
gukash contemplates you know yet another
challenging position
cdcd Knight takes E4 is a worthy attempt
and I do see that after Queen E4 Queen
C4 Queen A8 why uh wins the yeah Bishop
A6 there there's also this move Knight
C6 here which is actually really tricky
and if white plays a random move Queen
takes F1 and Bishop A6 wins the queen
back with interest so it's check on the
king and the black Rook takes the queen
next there is also Bishop A6 instead of
then and then Knight seat uh yeah yeah
it's
you should be six work moves and then oh
there's Knight D2 Tempo and defense but
then you take and then both Rooks are
hanging so you can see the Evo bar is
not giving as overwhelming of an
assessment as you would expect being
down a rook maybe Queen C3 also to keep
Knight C6 alive but anyways good cash
he probably explored that angle he
decided against it and he's gone for the
more
sort of pedestrian Knight bd7
yeah
well unpleasant unpleasant I think
Magnus will play Bishop G5 as discussed
and what happens in these structures
done if we can highlight the bishop will
come to G5 and if white gets his way
you'll play E5 at some point and that
Bishop on C4 can even slide back to D3
and the structure has now changed where
white is opening up space toward the
king side and so he plays E5 right away
very similar right oh he's all in Knight
G5 here we go this is going to be an
attack
he just says I'm going to Checkmate you
because you don't have a dark skirt
bishop and after H6 the knight's gonna
swing back to E4 you see that so often
in these positions are you going to D6
not necessarily you're actually just
normally going Queen H5 and then sack on
H6 Danny and Lucas is just so passive
here
yeah this is
he doesn't even want the bishop to
develop there he's like Knight G5 first
MBD which is obviously South African for
I'm gonna Checkmate you NBD here we go
and and Knight G5 Queen H5 is coming
don't even care about the C3 Pawn
by the way the clock has reached zero
which means this is officially the last
game we will see in the five minute
portion after our quick break of course
we will have three minute Blitz and uh
when we see adoption we'll be seeing
epic comeback
will we see Don you slip in more Awkward
puns than makes any of us comfortable
you gotta watch and find out you're
gonna have to stick around always yes
always yes I should point out by the way
Knight takes C3 there was Queen to D3
forking yeah made threat and the Knight
on C3 there's that Knight going back to
E4
Magnus is 32-78 that is quite the blitz
rating
32 foaming at the mouth looking at that
number I mean
looking to go on a bender and grab that
leaderboard
oh yeah I'm about 160 points away at the
moment it is true a good comment from
from Beijing chess King the point is
we're going to see a lot of instructive
stuff regardless of whether this is as
close a match as a roni and andrekin
let's say that went literally the
distance we're probably not going to see
that let's be honest but we will see a
lot of instructive chefs and this
re-coordination of whites of White's
pieces in White's forces with Tempe E5
Knight g594 it's super instructive stuff
sorry that's what do you want to say
words and you just want to make noises I
kind of just want to make noises because
the words have been spoken by the move
F6 I like that move by gukash I think
that's what you have to do if you're
black here because otherwise Queen H5
and Bishop H6 was yeah you know
basically over red Rovers Mufasa likes
to say Mufasa say it again Mufasa
Madness
Madness ooh makes me
this is flying over my head you've never
seen Lion King
I I've seen I've never seen the movie in
its entirety
I've seen I know who Mufasa is and I
know simbons I know the storyline I just
I've never seen the entire movie
I'm not a big like Disney guy you know I
Mulan Milan is the only movie I've seen
like multiple times the only Disney
movie God what a random movie do you
have seen multiple times I don't even
loved Mulan
it's it's good but it's not top five all
right we're back Bishop Basics is on the
board
gives up the bishop and he says I'm
picking up this juicy little morsel on
E6 and then D5 is hanging after that the
knights under under attack and if the
Knight moves F6 is hanging oh my gosh
when you're up by so much and you know
Magnus doesn't take these kinds of risks
normally but he he knows he's got
nothing to lose he loses a game by
accident like this big deal you know my
lead is still five and that's the
terrifying thing about facing someone
like Magnus in this situation Queen G6
by the way is a totally viable
alternative here to Japan takes E6 no
you I went with Queen E6 because you
pointed it out but originally I was
thinking queen queen G6 was the move I
promise and now now what did you do I
mean
Queen takes H6 is coming next
in some positions I can even just trade
on D5 if we're moving that Knight allows
allows F6 to fall with temp B depending
on the spot this is
this is no fun by the way Rook G8 let's
show Rook G8 on the board we don't even
need analysis but just show Rook G8 eval
bar that's Checkmate
let's get down to big one to defeat the
Hans and go cash down to 10 seconds this
one's over this one's over Knight B8
Knight B8 might be the only way to
connect the queen on the king side but
that drops F6
oh God I would take take
or take go back and maybe go F4 Rook F3
which I think you pointed out
yeah yeah magnitude removing it all he's
not getting more F4 The Rook lift shelst
commence put the Rook on the elevator
slide it up run bulbs your uncle over
down H file get him down there all right
here we go I mean it's it's happening
it's happening I think hip2hop uses the
best word in such a situation Relentless
that's totally what Magna says he is
Relentless and he just keeps pummeling
you and he does not let up it's human
nature to let up in these situations but
if anything Magnus just plays with more
confidence
can we actually give a shout out that if
Magnus wins this game smarter chess was
wrong smarter chess predicted seven and
a half one and a half take that Matt
it'll be eight to one of Magnus and now
what's up now what they missed the Mark
didn't waste
not going gentle into that good night
but Rook D3 is gonna come anyway I think
yeah and then it's mate
I said it before you can highlight it
take that I said it first you got me I
saw you got me there
what's what's taking him so long Rook D3
is the easiest move the whole game Rook
D3 Knight F4 Queen H6 King G8 Rook G3
king of seven Queen oh there was Queen
H7 and Bishop B5 check did he miss
Bishop B5 at the end maybe that was it
I mean Rook D3 Bishop C8 though uh but
then Rook G3 is over no that's over okay
it's over yo whoa well eight to one is
the score meaning smarter chess was
wrong first place is steak knives second
place is you're fired Matt just kidding
buddy all right here we go let's take a
look at the match scores where Magnus
Carlson is currently dominating his
round of 16 matchup versus damaraju
gukesh Dania H1 what has been most
impressive so far uh in your view from
the world champion
the margins of Victory the fact that he
has missed you know four or five readily
clearly identifiable game-winning
tactics whether it's Checkmate or like
material and all of those games he has
still won very smoothly and that just
tells you about the way this guy
positions his pieces yeah again the
margin of error that Magnus has is crazy
like he can miss everything as Akila
said in the chat and still win game
after game that's why we love him that's
why we watch him I was going to say the
same thing slightly differently what's
been most impressive is that he hasn't
even been super sharp or impressive and
yet there is the score out doing even
the smarter chess predictions we'll see
what good cash can come up with in the
three minute portion but before we go to
break let's remind everybody that today
is December 6th in case you were
wondering where you are and what day it
is and it's also optic Gaming's annual
giving streamathon benefiting Children's
Health the botes sisters are joining the
stream for some hand in brain chests at
6 30 Pacific time check out our partners
the boat test sisters over there you can
tune in at twitch.tv optic gaming to
catch their segment and support the
Child Life program for children's health
so all right there you go now you know
what you're doing after the show but me
and Don you've still got a lot more of
this show ahead don't go anywhere when
we return it's more from the round of 16
matchup between Carlson and gukesh and
the three minute portion is just around
the corner
[Music]
what is this this is duck chess you guys
this is a new variant it's called duck
chess chess but with a duck quack quack
how to play duck chest the duck is a
brick pieces cannot move through the
square occupied by the duck okay kind of
square to place the duck
[Music]
oh he put the deck to prevent moves of
opponent not yourself
Yeah so basically you do this and this
cannot move I'm gonna go Knight F6 and
I'm gonna put the duck in the most
inconvenient place for my opponent to
move no Bishop no Queen so no londons
can permanently stop the London capture
the puns King to win oh wow though
there's no stalemates but still wait
there is still meat but the still made
the player wins ooh if only that was
real chess I think I'm getting the hang
of this game I think I think I actually
am getting the hang of it
I think this works oh that's a horrible
blunder oh my God I just blundered I
have to move something else first then
dark and Knight will take my king this
is the best way to lose the dog chest
[Music]
there are some real bullet skills right
there boys this is the fast time winning
duck chest
oh no no no no no no slip no no no no no
no
ah duck chess champion give me those
points baby
[Music]
all right
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh we missed it oh he allowed to drop oh
my goodness the wheels the wheels have
come out that could be the match for
some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness Knight d8 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby
electric six oh that was a sick tactic
the moves will be fast this game over
it's winning oh my God yes it is he's
gonna make a queen the stakes will be
high he just grabs his head he can't
believe it he just gave away the pawn
the 2022 speed Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
welcome back everybody to yet another
round of 16 matchup for the 2022 speed
Chess Championship International Master
Danny wrench alongside the one and only
Grandmaster Donya nerdinsky uh we've got
the one and only Magnus Carlson World
chess champion putting on a show here
for the fans as we move into the
three-minute portion Donya he leads by a
score of eight to one
Switching gears your go Cash's coach
what are you telling the young fella
that he can do here to focus on what
matters
well you got to be realistic and at this
point it's it's way you know you're way
past the point of thinking about a
comeback you'll start thinking about a
comeback if you can reduce this down to
a four-point lead right now once again
try to get off to a good start you've
got a different time control you've got
to reduce time control and that means
more crazy stuff can happen yeah so I
honestly kukasha's coach would be in a
very unenviable spot right now yeah well
you know but I think you said it well
which is that you can't focus on the
comeback right now you focus on the one
game at a time there's nothing we can do
besides make those Sports cliche
references but comebacks do happen uh
for those tracking I believe the biggest
deficit we've ever had in SCC history
overcome was a five game deficit and the
biggest deficit we ever had overcome in
the bullet portion was indeed four games
so Dania maybe accidentally board game
marker or you did it uh with that
knowledge on you but yes the biggest
deficit we ever saw uh come back from
was a four game deficit headed into
bullet yeah and and right now gokesh has
to focus on not getting adopted of
course the prizes are pretty
mouth-watering and there's that
percentage that's uh of the prize that's
split by win percentage Yeah that's more
motivation for kukesh to make this a
close match even if he ultimately does
not end up uh pulling off the greatest
comeback in SEC history against the
strongest player in chess history and we
talk about that a lot it's one of the
things we like about the SCC format
obviously those who are tuning in just
to see who wins we know that it's not
your favorite storyline but it is
something that we like about the format
because the truth is it keeps you
fighting for something and these aren't
you know just like a couple bucks you're
playing for every game could be you know
worth upwards of a couple hundred
dollars right and so there's something
to play for there certainly for good
cash in addition to just putting on a
good fight and and doing what he can to
keep pace
let's see what he comes up with here in
the first couple of games of the three
minute portion it's the three plus one
is just a completely different game from
five plus one but Magnus has been
playing with such speed and confidence
especially in the last couple of games
that I'm still pretty worried about Goku
cashier and we have a kind of a weird
Kings Indian attack with a pawn situated
on B5 yeah it's it's the uh the B5
extension that when it first started
getting played they said was it a mouse
slip and then they're like wait it's
over the board you can't slip with a
mouse so you meant to do that
um it's like those videos where Hikaru
grabs you know the imaginary Mouse on
the left side of the board yeah no
there's nothing there just you know we
we've come so far that these days more
online chess happens than than over the
board chess uh but uh yeah the b-pawn
extending to actually talk about why you
do it if you're black gaining that space
makes a lot of sense and you hear you
see uh A5 Advanced after the B Pawn and
when you put your pieces behind pawns
particularly the knights often they can
do more damage you see white doing the
same thing on the king side with the G
Pawn followed by Knight to G3 uh for
good cash but but Magnus just
he's acting like he's been here before
giving his shoulder a scratch right
there that was an old an old pawn push
injury coming back to hunt Magnus Oh I
pushed that pawn too hard over there let
me massage that one out stretch the
muscle yeah he's gonna stretch some of
the White's muscles on the queen side
here if you can slip in A3 and force B3
then the entire complex of dark squares
is massively weakened you often see the
Knight dropping into D4 and Black's
attack just kind of plays itself on the
queen side yeah
uh what okay I do like Queen D2 I like
Bishop H6 coming
I know I'm not gonna check mate Uganda
but you know a Boy Can Dream hey you've
checked mad at me before you can do it
again oh you you're so kind although it
Tokyo until the end game but you did it
eventually
that's right uh although
um
have you told everybody that I own our
over the board plus record
well that's what I was heavily implying
oh okay I was being I was being tasteful
about it you know with a whopping score
when have I ever been tasteful I've
never been accused of being tasteful
okay
um and no I'm kidding well and you made
me cry after the game so no I didn't
come on I was definitely tearing up a
little bit yeah but you cried after
every loss at that point that's true you
were totally true I mean I'm pretty sure
I beat you when you were like you know
six or something like that not quite you
were a Master Level player but it was uh
you were still little enough that you
had to sit on a phone book I think
yeah it was it was there was a great
sort of a gradual process of the object
becoming smaller at first it was a
booster seat yeah
um then there was a different booster
seat and then his phone book you know
and then finally I could just sit on the
chair yeah and now I I have to bring the
chair down now you do now you're right
now you're you're uh tall lanky guy all
right
93 Queen B1 I guess there's Rook D1 uh
it was a disaster for Dwight
93 Brooks he goes for it anyway yeah he
just doesn't care he just says I'm gonna
go after your A3 Pawn I don't need your
Rook I'm happy to give up two minor
pieces for The Rook
such a such an interesting point to show
that the initiative obviously the
ability to create threats more than more
important than you know what we normally
favored the two pieces are usually good
against The Rook but with black taking
D3 playing Queen B3 and if the trade
happens that b-pawn just pushes up the
board and you know or Rook C3 right the
point is white just doesn't have time to
bring that Bishop on G2 that Knight on
G3 the ones you're highlighting uh back
into the game so Magnus Magnus flexing
gukesh already under a minute on the
clock he's got 99 problems and Magnus
Carlson is one of them exactly and that
night on G3 is just the worst piece in
White's position it has zero prospects
and that's the problem with minor pieces
they're just not oh but now 3v1 is over
now you should have one I guess still
holds on
but I mean there must be a knockout here
maybe bishop C3 at some point can be
thrown in
but even like Queen B1 and Rook C2 right
you're just like you bring the pieces in
and you say here you go there you go how
you like them apples huh
I mean anything Queen B2 Rook C2
immediately uh
no this is this is dead lost and Magnus
has so much time it's time management
Danny
we take it for granted yeah but the
world champions time management might be
the best of anybody at the top like we
almost never talk about Magnus getting
into like super severe time pressure in
classical chess and thus far in this
blitz match you know his is phenomenal
just sense of when to invest a long
think is is just so impressive Bishop D4
Chuck thrown in
is it Queen B1 or Rook C2 again I I
would predict Queen B1 because that
threatens mate on G1
yeah I mean if you can believe that yeah
Queen B1 threatens mate forces Bishop F1
in the same way that it was forced
before though to be fair to guard The
Rook on D3 and still Rook C2 comes in
and so
this is Queen B1 Rook C2 Bishop takes D3
said by Said by chat double double Jared
here it comes Rook C2 yeah this position
plays itself here which is yep pretty
dejecting for Mr gukesh yep
what a disaster of a position
and now Bishop d
yeah you can even play Queen D1 okay no
he takes first
oh he's simplifying oh it's just this is
just a vintage Magnus this is so vintage
Magnus Rook A2 oh you win the piece at
the end oh my gosh oh if Bishop A4 Rook
A3 Fork the bishop and Knight on G3
everybody that's why he had to give up
the a pawn and now Carlson will push the
a pawn you got a baby girl Anita Anita's
coming to A1 or uh or or
or Andrea or any Nea name I just made it
up
um well that's like daenerys's dragons
they're gonna grow pretty quickly and
gukash just resigns and now we're
entering adoption territory
yep
that wasn't fair go cash never got off
the ground on the king side like he got
his Knight to Chi through he did
everything you're supposed to do Danny
he made All the Right Moves pressed all
the right buttons and then his Attack
Just evaporated
yeah
well you know it is harder to launch
those King's Indian attack positions
those style positions against a fee and
Kettle structure and Magnus knew that
right that H7 G6 I mean I don't want to
get too abstracted it's not on the board
anymore but just I your comments made me
think in my head going full chess player
never go full chess player on a chess
show Robert Downey Jr taught me that
never go full chess player
um but in my full chess player mode the
problem is down here those types of
attacks for white are much stronger in a
traditional King's inning attack where
let's say whites uh Black's Bishop is on
E7 right the fee and Kettle structure is
hard to attack with that type of
formation and we saw that gukesh never
really got anything there
no you're absolutely right and Magnus
just kind of going away from Theory with
a smooth A3
uh stopping the Bishop from developing
to B4 and now heathian ketos which is
very popular now in uh all E6 Sicilians
to film Kettle the light squirt bishop
and just get a you know a sicilian
that's more on the positional side yep
Alexander Ivana preferred these
positions as a kid growing yeah in the
uh yeah
a couple of kids growing up in the
American chess circuit right deutschberg
tournaments weren't healthy for anybody
let's be honest but um Alexander Ivana
for Grand Master who played a lot of
these structures you can also play them
with A4 for white this is as Don just
said it's positional you still strive at
times for the traditional here he goes
he goes back to A4 you can go for F4 at
some point the Chevy engine structure
with the fee and Kettle set up for white
is often very solid
and Magnus just understands every type
of position it literally doesn't matter
what you throw at him he will know the
typical plans and the typical ideas
in literally every opening and every sub
variation something that we also take
for granted by the way but something
which is exceedingly rare even at the
highest level to know as many patterns
and as many ideas as Magnus knows
you know it's like a restaurant where
the menu encompasses every single
Cuisine and the chef you know is the
best chef in the world at you know
whatever Cuisine you want it's crazy
I'm hungry with a lot of options I'm
thinking Cheesecake Factory I don't know
what you're doing afterwards I love
Cheesecake Factory
except there's only one of them here and
it's and the line extends to South
Carolina so
um all right but we see this little
maneuver the night goes from B5 to D4
followed by a double fiend Kettle setup
it's a very easy position for white to
play and you know again to give our boy
Robert Hess a shout out we often look at
the pawn breaks it's hard for black to
play D5 here which is often a strike you
want in a sicilian because that Bishop
on G2 is primed and holding it you can't
play for A6 and B5 even though you'd
like to that's also a typical Sicilian
break but White's ahead of the game with
A4 holding it back maybe even C4 is
going to come here for Magnus so it is
again you're highlighting it and I'm
just pointing out that this is a tough
position because Black's got pieces that
look okay but where's the Breakthrough
where do we give them some Liberty
no this is just a buzz saw kind of
position Rook from A1 coming to D1
Magnus opting for the bishop pair which
which makes I mean the bishop on G2 is
not the greatest piece in the world but
it's it's a solid Bishop it's protecting
E4 E5 could come at in inopportune
moment not yet yeah because black will
push D5 and that transformation is in
Black's favor but Magnus holds all the
pawn breaks I think he's gonna drop his
Bishop back to B2 and maybe launch a
king side attack there he goes H4 is a
way to do that too H4 is a the alpha
zero special you Advanced that one poke
and prod a little bit it'll come back
and bite your opponent I love your
Bishop
go ahead PNP Pokemon prod
all day all day every day we Shuffle and
Shuffle and shuffling
um
okay now we have a hedgehog without the
feeling killer Bishop for black
I don't know that I like A5 I like B5
quickly from ucash even if it's not
correct I like the speed by the way he's
up on the clock for the first time and
well it's it's been a minute according
to my watch since gukesh was ahead on
the clock
as I say that as I say that I think I
actually think this idea of going A5 by
Magnus is very instructive I think he's
gonna go C4 and try to play against this
A6 Pawn which he's fixed as a long-term
weakness but in order to get get access
to it he has to eliminate the B5 Pawn
which is of course its Pawn cover yeah I
think C4 is is on the menu here just to
continue my restaurant on LG C3
Poland is upon give me that take it that
might have been a mouse that might have
been a mouse club actually like he meant
to play C4
I mean
and gukesh took a while there just look
at that too good to be true that'll wake
you up do you see that oh whoa no he
literally just went like WTF why the
face as as these kids didn't know that's
what it means why the face why the face
why the face uh WTF
yeah I used to think it means uh like
FTW is for the win
I used to think it means win the four
it's just like a typo
you are about as adorable as I also
thought Mississippi was a person but
Steve what is going on he's imploded
Magnus is falling apart here and what
does he do like he shakes his head he's
laughing it off now because uh he took a
position with with all
all the moves into a lost end game zero
one and he's gonna lose a piece too he
blundered a piece on top of everything
else yeah Bishop let's just show a world
is in your head or show Rook D4 Bishop
D4
is hanging
and if you go Bishop E7 then gouquet
should go Rook to D7 here
it happened but it's over wow no
adoption great game by gukesh I mean he
just picked up the pawns Magnus was
offering him and that means the hood is
coming off Magnus reveals a fully fluffy
head of hair how big can that hair get
we've done that Meme before
um well gukesh strikes back and it's not
over yet it's not over it's not a dooba
It's Not Over
wait who was that
Welcome to California that's not a tumor
am I it's it's like one of those things
it's like you're you're setting a trap
where like
I have to get the reference or else
everybody in chat's gonna start laughing
at me even though it's like Limp Biscuit
or something
[Laughter]
it's Robert hessen and my inside joke is
Limp Biscuit because you made a Limp
Biscuit reference and I didn't get it
that's like our stand-in for how
narrative he doesn't get any common
references oh my God
yeah
now that I
if you tell me at Schwarzenegger it
makes sense I just didn't you know
it just didn't occur to me naturally
okay I know all right it's nine to two
there likely will not be an adoption in
this match so for those who had the
secret betting line on some website
there that not that I endorse or or or
would approve that in any way I'm just
saying if there are betting lines that
exist and someone had a side parlay that
an adoption would occur before the one
minute portion you have loss or you will
not win your money back because there's
not going to be enough games or time on
the clock for Magnus to win 10 in a row
yeah exactly
okay so we have a London system once
again I like kukesha's position what
would really do wonders for his
confidence Danny is a two-game winning
streak yes because beating Magnus more
than one and Magnus is frustrated I
again I've tried to make a conscious
effort and commentary of making less
observations about body language ever
since Fabi gave an interviewer I think
he made an incredibly wise statement
about like commentators overdoing it on
a body language front plus you're the
Magnus body language Whisperer but he is
frustrated and this is the perfect time
to exploit that and he's playing very
fast is gukesh
yeah I mean you got to start somewhere
we said it right uh one game at a time
you know and so you gotta win you're in
a good position here with the bishop
here you're up 40 seconds on the clock
I mean
can't ask for more at this point
um
yeah I mean
it's a seven point match plays B3 no
this is good play by gukesh he's better
out of the opening here
you can't really ask for more than a
bishop pair a space advantage on the
king side and in some positions Danny
there are ideas of like Knight G5 Knight
take C6 here which you can't fall asleep
on Mufasa
[Laughter]
there you go and maybe 94 C4 undermine
those uh pawns and open up your Bishop I
like it I like it she's up a minute on
the clock Magnus is a little frustrated
head in hand despite fobby saying we
read too much into it with all due
respect Bobby chess is a people watching
Sport and that's what people didn't
understand forever it's not just a chess
watching Sport and this and this is a
Magnus who's frustrated and if we bring
up an announcement real fast real fast
here's a perfect example of Knight takes
G6 working like a charm FG you could
even throw in Bishop takes D6 very nice
and what and everything is I mean both
Rooks the bishop and the other Rook
absolutely I like it yeah all right that
was fantastic
um Queen C8 by the way by Magnus guards
E6 preventing said tactics
um Rook A7 also sort of prophylactic and
aggressive in nature from Carlson you
can put the Rook on C7 and attack the C3
Pawn I wonder if Lucas should still play
C4 I guess Magnus will play Knight takes
C4 there because C4 DC walks into Knight
C6
okay we're about to find out Bobby okay
we found out any day bro any day bro
chess is a people watching Sport and
you're welcome okay we're bringing for
bringing the fans
um I'm not saying I'm not saying that
commentators don't sometimes read into
body language that isn't there I am
saying that reading into body language
is half of what makes watching you guys
interesting when you're sitting there
for six hours bro Abby just said he'd
fight you I mean we've got toxic suppose
I do for some reason I knew Favi was
lurking and I knew if I said that he
would show himself I I I literally had a
feeling I knew that he was lurking you
just got caught Bobby debated debated
next chess boxing match somehow Magnus
has managed to stabilize this so maybe
C4 actually was premature Now The Rook
coming to D7 so at this point for gukesh
playing against Black's clock might be
his best bet try to keep the tension
yeah improve your position bit by bit
maybe play against the A6 Pawn this is
what Magnus wanted to do in the previous
game except he blundered all of his
pawns yeah and then his piece what a
weird train wreck of a game that was
last game I don't feel like we've
doubled down on that against against
Magnuson that was I was very odd I mean
starting with C3 yeah it was bad enough
to blunder upon but then he just
followed up with his entire Queen side
no but if it is true for those who might
just be tuning in I mean okay I don't
know that we're going to see an epic
comeback but one of the storylines has
been Magnus is obviously up on the
scoreboard but it hasn't been super
sharp today yet and and so when you see
a game like that happen where he the
wheels came off you worry if you're
Magnus you don't want to lose two in a
row I don't know that that's gonna
happen but he is now under 30 seconds on
the clock and he's still under serious
pressure on the board your knight on D5
is a great piece but you've got a
long-term weakness on A6 and gukashus
has better place pieces Queen C6 might
be unpleasant at some point look at how
fast cash is playing I love this queen
C6 that's what you gotta do move Grand
Master move exactly Queen B2
hits D4 good move from Magnus
that's that's a really good move
yeah you camp Under The Rook so maybe
Rook C2 but then I take only with the
queen and we're on the bishop even if I
lose A6 I feel like I can draw if I'm
Magnus
I mean Rook C2 Queen D4 and then Bishop
takes D5 Maybe
I mean that a pawn runs real fast oh but
cash now down to 30 seconds himself I
like how you said real fast let's get
ready to run oh wait I'm not allowed to
say that he'll sue me
um it's my announcer voice
Bishop D5
Queen D5 Queen A6 Rook D5 he's gonna
allow Queen A6
well he wants to go after the a pawn but
why does a back rank check to pave the
way this is this is Maybe
the best game we've seen googesh play
since game one where he did win his
White Queen C8 and A6
yeah but now you're gonna Jinx him you
spoke the words oh no duck on the wood I
knocked on wood Thunder is coming he's
going for checkmate I think but Queen A8
is a dead end I mean he has the G6
Square uh uh oh rookie chick Queen G8
though oh and the queen goes to H7 back
door baby girl here we go
speaking of back door he now has f6s and
escapes oh and queen black that was huge
queen of Fortune
anybody's game anybody's game rookie two
maybe
Rook D5 cuts off the queen so the queen
of four can draw he's gonna play Queen
of four Queen E4 Rook D5 one second move
oh my gosh oh my gosh Queen oh he gave
up the pawn oh now Magnus is probably
gonna win
Queen D6 check trades Queens if he wants
it one second for kukesh Queen E5 Queen
E5 Queen E5 oh Rook D4 he's got H5 it's
almost flagged one second two seconds oh
Rook G4 H oh my God
I was thinking that too but not the same
matter
oh my God what a hard breaker for gukesh
it is all your fault it actually all
went downhill after you uh labeled that
try to pin this on me you take your
Voodoo you take your Juju back you take
your Voodoo back you focus on fighting
Fabi and you got it all focus on
fighting Fabi you focus on throwing me
under the bus when I'm not on camera
with you and Robert all right do your
job by throwing me under the bus when
I'm not around
um deal any any Hooters wow okay the
point is down here we all just blacked
out and Magnus wins again
Mufasa Mufasa
that was just wild
oh man that's ridiculous and and that
was honestly
you know I don't want to say most
impressive game for Magnus but to be
able to turn things around at the drop
of a hat like that Danny and then Magnus
never just turns it around and draws it
he could have traded Queens there in
like six different occasions but he just
knows exactly when he needs to squeeze
things out and play for a win it's an
unbelievable Talent actually no it
really is and there's a it's a sixth
sense a sixth sense excuse me sorry
Haley Joel Osmond almost said that movie
with it with a list last good work you
ever did in Hollywood just kidding Sin
City was also great Sin City was also
great thank you Haley Joel any Hooters
um it's a sixth sense that these guys
have especially the generation of these
world's Elite Dania who grew up online
right there's an intuitive field they
have for the pressure and the
willingness to play with just the
increment on the clock you are part of
that generation too you're also very
good under time pressure I will
compliment you so you don't have to ah
it's one of the things that makes you so
good in those moments but obviously
these guys are doing it with all due
respect on another level right Magnus
and Carter these guys are and there's an
intuitive field they have to not take
the draw there that is just like
mind-blowing in hindsight and we take so
many things for granted one another
thing we take for granted to piggyback
off of your point is how little they
blunder not just how good they play in
time pressure in general but how little
they blunder with no time on their clock
I don't understand how they do it I mean
they get these super complicated
positions and their blunder rate is is
of course blunders happen in time
pressure but exceedingly rarely yeah
with you know two seconds for the rest
of the game it's it's just nuts it's
honestly these guys are just amazing yep
Magnus inviting the g-pawn to fall and
you can already feel the wind being
taken out of gukesh's sail just look at
the clock yeah what happened after that
other win dukesh was confident he was up
a minute at one point in that last game
and then here goes Magnus stealing
Victory from the jaws of defeat and now
gukesh is you know kind of back in a
position where he's a little worse no
longer up on time
yes I love to move Bishop D3 chat you
know talking remind you if you hold alt
when you promote you can under promote
even if you have Auto Queen on
um
we've learned that lesson the hard way
Queen takes G2 would have walked into
castle queenside and you cannot afford
to open up the G file with the White's
Bishops yeah I think they're called
Horowitz Bishops this is how it was at
least taught to me when you've got one
Bishop on the long diagonal and one on
the B1 H7 I usually call them horror
movie Bishops but you know same thing
um yeah gukesh is about to star in a
horror movie once these pawns get set in
motion yep are you a star and a horror
to say if you die early in the movie
hashtag Drew Barrymore hashtag who was
the famous actress who died in the
beginning of psycho
um oh my gosh I'm not talking about the
Remake I don't even want to talk about
that movie no no you're talking about
the 60s original the good yeah yeah
Hitchcock um uh anyway are you a star if
the movie starts with you dying because
you set the tone for the narrative I
would argue yes you are you were and it
wasn't was it Jamie Lee Curtis
oh no Jamie Curtis says Mom that's right
it was her mom wow that's right that's
how you remember it I forget her name
but she's a famous actress
um
um yeah Tony Curtis was was her dad I
forget the name too yeah anyway Jamie
Lee Curtis's mom died in the beginning
of the original Psycho hashtag
remembered that real good
okay
yeah Chad's gonna get Janice Janet Janet
yeah okay thanks
okay it was scream where's Drew
Barrymore died yes all right so Knight
B7 is played the ponies are relocating
but all white has to do is recarovka
King side Here Comes E5 nice here comes
E5 no but but the Knight coming to D6 I
actually think magnus's decision to play
E4 was premature as reflected in his
time usage okay yeah Fair yeah because
the more you say it when the Knight
comes to D6 if E4 E5 is played you can
trade on F5 and D5 Falls Bingo yeah okay
I feel you I feel you now there are
tactics Galore with a check on E3 ooh
there's got to be something here maybe a
sack on D5 let's think
um drawing a blank but you see what I'm
saying I mean White's position is very
flimsy but if Magnus can Castle kingside
everything magically resolves itself and
then white is much better so black has
exactly one tempo to orchestrate
something against White's King
yeah
I'm good call Sam Jackson dying in that
shark movie it was deep deep blue
something no that was a band in the 90s
deep blue something something shout out
to you counting Counting Blue Cars deep
blue something I think anyway that was
Jaws John no he doesn't Sam Jackson is
not in Jaws bro it's a movie where the
sharks are super smart and they had some
brain steroids or something and like Sam
Jackson that's outside my yeah it's it's
deep it's deep something I know it was
deep something
um hello
that was the computer
okay that's what we call a joke G3 is
played and I like the the Dynamics of
this position here's what's funny about
this position done is like if you give
white two moves it's like over if white
gets like Bishop G2 and castles and then
just here comes everything but black
senses that and is going to make things
happen now while the king is still in
the center I like F5 even if it even if
the eval says a little better for white
well speaking of Jaws I mean
these two pawns and gukesh trying to
kind of work his way around it but okay
Queen B3 hits the Knight defends the
pawn Magnus going more uh
straightforwardly with Rook D1 there
there's also a discovery against the
other Bishop yeah uh Danny but I don't
think ukesh is going to be able to
handle this with no time I think now
Magnus can just castle and maybe allow
Knight takes G3 or King F2 oh I love
that like a badass that's he walks into
the face of danger puts his running shoe
shoes on
it's like 23. okay G1 I think
you can also just take D4
you could take D4 and then you give up
E5 though
wait now maybe there's some sort of
Knight F4 action
I see that the smarter just prediction
has reached a hundred percent hundred
percent hundred percent I mean that's
not really fair but okay queen of five
kukash is losing the thread and Magnus
is consolidating again but only five
seconds for Magnus is not over blunders
do happen come on gukesh put the
pressure rooksy oh did you wait black
was winning with Rook C2
oh what is going on are you sure about
that D6 Magnus gives up E5 D7 one second
five seconds
no 93 93 93's winning it's a huge threat
it's a huge threat
he was in check but he's coming
oh now Magnus there's no time
he's totally winning afternoon
safety seven and you win oh my gosh
I don't know how I just turned into like
a mom who's like lost her way finally in
the Bad scene of the movie where she's
broken I want my baby oh no exactly good
cash
and that's the lack of experience
speaking right there that's where it
comes in it's that it's as you said
you've been using the term Sixth Sense
yep another sixth sense that super
experienced Blitz players have is you
you can you can tell when you have 0.5
seconds even without looking at the
clock you just know when you have to
move yep yep
it's like you know basketball players
are shot luck to make another popular
sports reference yep yep yep
yep
okay oh my goodness okay all right we're
back to the Italian now remember
everybody the one game the the sorry the
first game gukesh won in this match was
on the white side of an Italian a very
different structure than the one we have
here
but okay we continue to look for a
threat of Hope here we pull we pool on
that thread just hoping there's like a
prize at the end of it you know
um at some point it gets harder to pull
and you're like did I catch something
turns out no it was just slightly stuck
on the angle you got nothing
um
but yeah
11 to 2 Magnus Carlsen leads
yeah and this is the last game before
the break Magnus driving his Pawn into
D4
so they have a repeat of
you know one of the two games the kukash
won that Italian game where he put his
Knight on D5 that was by far good
catcher's best game in the match that
was a phenomenal game yep unfortunately
he needed about 11 more of those games
and he's gotten zero yep
change to King H7 I like it
King H2 King H7 I for an eye don't hang
the F7 Pawn Magnus plays Bishop E7 to
prepare F5 more than likely yeah black
is better here again I mean gukesh is
not effective on the king side and the
queen side is completely dried up
oh
yeah you have to go King G2 that's not a
good sign
dukesh is keeping his composure I agree
with you chat also keeping it fresh with
that white button down there he always
looks like he's about to go be someone's
best man at a wedding can we just say
that about dukesh typically looks well
cloth
yeah he is very well dressed I actually
have noticed that yeah
and he's Immaculate impeccably classy
but this kind of match would get to
anybody and he's much worse again I mean
Magnus is playing so effortlessly at
this stage of the match
oh there's that water again there's that
islar isklar I see Diamond member
symphonic Knight who's chatting on the
chefs.com chat directly asking when MBL
would face Magnus if it gets that far I
I I don't know any no one wants to face
Magnus uh but yes you're asking an
interesting question because mvl is the
only person ever in history to beat
Magnus Carlson in the speechless
championship
and for now it's going to stay that way
this is white is like dead here yep
Danny E4 is coming next to a theater
near you
and I don't see a single way to defend
against that threat if only you could
bring your knight back to D2 but white
is one tempo Too Short yep
it's really true the uh little things
start getting you here
when uh you're one Temple behind always
one maneuver behind one positional
blockade behind you you almost have to
play G4 to kick the bishop and then put
your queen on you I can't even complete
it because it feels wrong coming out of
my mouth
well G4 Bishop takes G4 doesn't help uh
he goes well okay well there you go I I
guess I unfortunately wheeled it into
existence for gukesh you Danny Danny's
commentator curse strikes again oh and
look at this line Rook takes F3 Queen E4
Rook takes F2 and Rook f8 is basically
my lands
there you go
you're learning
getting a little sketchy a little sketch
around here when Danny starts
there are Zero moves oh he goes right
we're gonna see it on the board we're
gonna do man just finds it oh he
finishes in style
oh and go Kesh saw that he just there
was just like no other moves so he was
just playing Hope Chest at that point
no it makes sense it's Josh
it's uh rubbing
it's hurting a little bit because she
knows it's a halftime break Magnus
apparently didn't eat before the match
started it's the memo on proper you know
body management because he has been
stuffing his face I think that's the
third banana he's had today
uh we oh we are going to take
only only our second break of the day uh
obviously we've still got a lot ahead
here there is the back half of the 3-1
portion and ultimately bullet uh so
don't go anywhere everyone lots of
instructive moments but it is the Magnus
Carlsen show we are watching it is the
SCC in the year of 2022 and Donya and I
will be right back
thank you
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play and
chess kid makes it easy to have fun
whether your child is a total beginner
or a prodigy they can hop on and find a
well-matched opponent from around the
world at any time chess kid is the safe
parent-approved way for your child to
play chess online
chess kid is educational
to kids it feels just like playing but
chest is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
50 000 chest muscles and a whole library
of entertaining videos that teach
strategies tactics openings and end
games specifically for kids
chess kid is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
[Music]
chess kit is fun chess is great for the
brain but it's also fun to play
[Music]
foreign
how many chairs does one world champion
need apparently two isn't even enough
because he's somewhere else
and and there's a couch how many sitting
surfaces and the floor you can always
sit on the floor yeah
for sure so that's like six and there's
another chair on the left side if you
look the core there's a corner of yet
another chair yeah that's the fair play
chair hey fair play Team not to be
confused with the other 18 chairs yeah
that are facing 17 different directions
at least we're working hard fair play
team and Magnus has got that phone
plugged in you don't want it to lose
charge
uh in the middle of a match
speaking of uh losing charge in the
middle of a match
Magnus Carlson has almost never ever
done that he's lost one sec match in his
career he's a five-time world chess
champion he's good at everything
according to our insights your thoughts
uh Donya on uh Magnus Carlson right now
well I'm just gonna Echo what I said
earlier it's human nature to let up a
little bit when you're up by four or
five that's why we see a good amount of
comebacks in the SEC you know we see
players go up big and then they kind of
slip a little bit not Magnus Carlson the
more he wins the better he becomes he
wasn't tactically as sharp uh at the
beginning of the match Danny but the
speed with which you just saw Rook takes
F2 what's scary is that Magnus is just
getting tactically better as the match
is progressing and
I mean that kind of speaks for itself
doesn't it yeah as it does for as does
the score four to one currently we still
have 30 minutes left
in the 3-1 portion for those uh just
getting here we got a lot of Chess ahead
and you know it's funny because we all
like to see the close matches we'd like
to see those matches that have us on the
edge of our seat Armageddon tiebreaker
shout out to you or Ronin on draken but
we also like to see greatness everyone
does right it's it's why we tune in when
when you see the best in the world doing
what they do and uh what will Magnus be
capable of today what will the young goo
cash in five years will someone like
gukesh be the dominant player in the
Chess World winning winning tournaments
and winning SEC matches you know when we
were in Toronto down here for the global
Championship I was asked by uh one of
the one of the reporters there from Indy
I think it might have been chess based
India asked with all the Young upstarts
from India in the SEC this year Eric icy
gukesh nihal sarin was this the year
they finally started getting it done and
I gave him the honest answer I think
they're I think they're still a couple
of years away but it's only a matter of
time I think before one of these
absolute monsters from India uh you know
starts winning the SEC and many other
events yeah for sure and and we still
have nihal sarin who you know I'm a huge
fan of and he is just a force to be
reckoned with of course our generic guys
he just put forth uh just a Wilding
performance at uh taught of Steel but
meeting his match in uh in in Fabby so
it's just there's just so many insane
players in the SEC the older generation
yeah he's going to give up the Reigns
that easily no no I love calling Fabi
part of the older generation is he still
here Bobby oh you're done you just said
he just called he's not letting that
comment generation about it
I mean even Magnus is part of the older
generation and he has looked a little
off today like I said hand on shoulder
rubbing rubbing out that old that old
pawn pushing injury you can hurt
yourself playing chess these days it's a
compliment from one old guy to another
Fabi one old guy to another
um
but uh yeah we we've we've had a lot of
people watching comments for a guy like
Fabi who says chess is not a people
watching sport LOL
um anyway what can gukesh do
to to just start feeling good one game
at a time
here he's black
in a uh
kind of looks like a reverse sort of
hedgehog Hedgehog structure excuse me uh
you can play C5 here next and kind of
cramp down on D4 and B4 it's not a bad
position for black if you can if you can
keep that space advantage yeah and and
we haven't talked as much about the
openings largely because you know Magnus
has steered the game away from Theory as
he usually does but even when he's done
that he's still better he's getting the
best of all worlds Danny I mean he's got
the bishop pair he's got a clearly
better position out of the opening and
he gets something non-theoretical so I
thought gukesh actually started off the
match on a very good note theoretically
wise but as the matches progressed he's
played right into magnus's hands in
every opening just look at Magnus just
sitting back in his chair blitzing out
the moves he's already up a minute you
know the narrative just keeps repeating
itself and he's even got Knight B7 if he
wanted it
E4 but there was a blunder there
yeah it just hangs the eighth one which
practice didn't even why would you take
free pawns come on
you could have done it but E4 is also
good because I don't know that Knight B7
is going anywhere right grab a Snickers
um
that's that's the terrifying thing about
I got all day Knight B7 can still come
oh God Magnus just going H4 no better
way to assert your dominance in a
position than just to be able to play a
move like that and still be much better
by the way Knight B7 is still a
possibility Magnus doesn't even want the
pawn
he wants gukesh to play F4 so that he
activates his light squirt Bishop
through H3 I think that's why he's
keeping things you called it look at you
guys for you I have my moments and I
think now he's gonna go 96 and so he
takes a four
and this is a very unpleasant position
G takes it for draw that diagonal baby
show him the pin the bishop on B2
dominates no the Diagon Style
I saw them move Queen C5 and it occurred
to me that that's a very Magnus s kind
of way to resolve the tension uh that's
right King G7 he'll play Queen I'm
calling it even if Rook G7 I'm calling
it he's gonna go Queen C5 if rookie
seven he plays gf4 I'll call him it
doesn't matter
oh man all right again damn girl it
again though it shows the fighting
Spirit like we're not beating up on good
cash before before the Rabid faithful
from India start bagging on us that's
not what we're doing we're literally in
awe of this generation coming up
seriously take the pitchforks home I I
say this because I've been doing this
for years relax but right now gukesh is
clearly you know obviously up against it
as many people have been against Magnus
and I'm actually going to say
complimentary complimentary uh gukesh
and saying that he resigns that game
janya because he still wants
to have a chance in this match he
doesn't want to just get beaten over the
head with a hammer he wants another game
to have it have an opportunity right you
have to compete against the clicking
clock right the counting down clock
above above their webcams there is just
as big of a problem as the scoreboard
and I I like that he resigns why why
torture myself
listen this isn't easy and you know no
matter how stalard of a Magnus fan you
are it's you know you're down you're
down by 10. you know you're you're kind
of walking into the narrative and and
this is not how gukesh envisioned it so
I I have to compliment him for not
tilting he's doing his best and you know
just sometimes you know you're playing
Mac you're playing a confident Magnus
and there's just there's just no scarier
opponent than Magnus when he's feeling
it they're just it's just Unstoppable
it's crazy
agreed they like my word compliments a
ring complimentary it's like when
romulans when you're trying to mentor
and compliment a mentoring compliment or
is it you're mentioning I'm not sure not
that I would be a mentor for gukesh I'm
I'm but I was acknowledging that I think
that he has it in him he has the fight
in him and he doesn't want this to be
you know a cakewalk for magnets he wants
more games give me give me more
opportunities let's also pause for a
second and note that gukash is still 16
years old that's crazy I mean how many
years he still has until we even start
talking about him reaching his prime
already well over 2 700 already
established
I mean some of these players just have
such Bright Futures it's nuts yep
okay degree degree another Hedgehog
another Hedgehog we've seen a lot of
double fee and ketos starting at the 3-1
portion that's what the Hedgehog is
defined as for those who don't speak
chess too good yet you got double
Bishops on G7 and B7 double Bishops on
B2 and G2
double fee and Kettles double the fun
taste the replacement of Doublemint gum
this segment brought to you by
Doublemint gun who will soon be
sponsoring double fiend Kettle positions
in chess
wow that was beyond smooth that delivery
double mint gum is underrated
double man I thought single man gun was
underrated but you know that's not what
the cool kids are talking about
apparently oh man Queen takes G2 the end
game has been invited for gukesh I like
it actually by the way Knight B5 is is a
move Magnus can't afford to to miss
right there's a spot coming for Knight
to B5 at some point I know yeah this is
in some trouble but the Rook is in
trouble
yeah that Rook is kind of similar to
what Hikaru had a trouble with in in his
pivotal game against Wesley in the cgc
when the Rook is in front of the pawns
like that uh it's it's a very very
vulnerable spot because the Rook can
never really go back right and here
comes go cash for the Snow White is
better here for sure and Magnus swinging
it to A5 like nothing's the matter B4
Rook A6
perfectly safe what could be better a V4
Rook A6 we're gonna see it oh he trades
means first you can can you go to G5 no
he's got to go to A6 this just how is he
playing this this is crazy and I was
half sarcastic in saying that nothing
could be better that Rook is actually
very well placed Danny because B5 or K5
and the Knight on C3 is actually tied
down to the pawn on A2 whereas you're
gonna have problems with the other Pawn
after Rook C8
super true oh my God one instructive
idea you can go for here is white is
move like A4 and then you're threatening
A5 and if B takes A5 you play B5 right
or and you're trying to create a problem
for The Rook while you expand uh your
your sort of mini three on two majority
over there on the queen side but G5
doesn't look great now there's Bishop
takes C3 and Rook takes A2 in addition
to the G5
and Rook C8 the old idea
I think ukesh was trying to to squeeze
in some sort of Knight D5 move but he's
got weak pawns now on both sides of the
board and again look at the clock he's
down 90 seconds in a three minute game
Magnus is not gonna not letting him
ready to free The Rook Free Willy
yeah this is no okay Rook A6 maybe you
can try to halt the progress of the ape
Pawn the last thing you want to allow is
a pass spawn on the king side on the
queen side yep
if you could somehow get D5 Rook A6 and
then March that King from F3 E4 D5 C6 I
understand I'm playing imaginary chess
and Magnus is like uh no thanks Dan I'm
gonna play A5 before you get B5 yep I'm
gonna go cash expanding on the king side
but with 16 seconds left we've seen
these steps of end games so many times
Magnus just never misses his chance here
here comes the a pawn here's Johnny
do you think this might motivate Mukesh
to play more online or is he's just sort
of focused on class and I mean there's
nothing wrong with that of course and he
his results speak for themselves but I'm
curious if this will be a slight impetus
for him to play a little bit more Blitz
maybe in preparation for next year's SCC
yeah I mean it depends on on on on how
you view it I guess I mean the truth is
that with more and more money in online
events and more and more opportunities
to play in events that matter right
online I think you know we've seen a
massive Changing of the Guard so the
reality is the narrative that before
that said I'm not going to waste my time
with online it doesn't seem to work
anymore because there's more probably
more prize opportunities uh more events
that matter
online and obviously the game is
evolving that way so I I mean obviously
to me the answer was yes you know you
should be looking to do that but at the
same time I think we're in a weird spot
Donya where I think some of these
youngsters like ukesh okay by the way
this game is getting spicy he's only got
five seconds but he but he is winning so
let's focus on that before we finish the
answer because she's winning and this is
one that he could actually play despite
the time Knight F5
wait no but Magnus is black oh Magnus is
black I lost my focus LOL I do that all
the time no Magnus is winning because
the Rook is coming to D2
okay no no obviously Magnus is winning
the whole time I just I as I was talking
I wait God who's who
it oh King A1 and there's a system
give up the bishop no
okay but it's obviously Magnus wouldn't
take the bishop even if he offered it in
that case yeah yeah when you've
self-salemate you still need your
opponent uh whoa to take your pieces
it's not a good move
allowing Bishop takes F3
and DC4 and the structure is uh not so
ideal is it no it's not also hey what I
was going to say is you have a
generation of players like goo cash
um who um are also being coached by the
generation who uh before them you know
came from a space where they wanted them
to focus more on classical right and I
think this there's a little bit of a
shifting of the Guard there where I
think some players prefer to play less
online some some players have sort of
embraced it I personally think that the
proof is in the pudding when you look at
guys like Carlson and Nakamura who grew
up playing online right and I don't
believe that fast time controls are bad
for your chest because guess what if
they were the best players in the world
would not would also not be the best
players at bullet and the best players
at Blitz like Magnus isn't just the best
classical chess player in the world he's
also the best at just about every other
time control right think about alireza
farouza also another example of someone
who literally grew up just playing 30
second chess all day and he ain't doing
too bad is he sorry Danny continue no no
you're just you're adding to the point
which is it's the same point right and I
think I think it doesn't mean there
aren't um opportunities or a time and
place to to focus on different muscles
of your of your chess game but the
answer is when there's 100 Grand on the
line and many many more where that came
from right you need to be in a position
to keep these matches close because it's
it's worth it's worth a lot of money
so yeah and and you know there's just so
many examples of of players of the Young
Generation who they play a lot online
they they they're good at all the mouse
tricks nihal sarin comes to mind I mean
he's unbelievably fast and yet if you
look at his classical chess style he
doesn't play superficially he's actually
an incredibly depositional player yeah
uh which is why I'm I'm honestly such a
big fan of nehal is he just manages to
find the balance uh and do everything I
mean he's ridiculously fast he's good at
you know tricky tactics which appeals to
my sensibilities I won't mention why but
he maintains the depth of his style it
is possible to do to have your cake and
eat it too I agree I agree and well it
doesn't speak of someone like Magnus
Carlson right just because Magnus is
fast and and knows how to be resourceful
and trick his opponents online doesn't
mean he's not playing high quality
positional chess so and I really like
mihal's game too I mean
um I said I said when we were in Toronto
that I feel like of all the young Indian
players
he somehow I think prognan dougash and
I'm not taking anything away from here
guys see any of them right but I feel
like nihal has a bit of an edge Factor
when I see him play his uh so fun to
watch yeah yeah and and I will not be
surprised if he moves on to the
quarterfinals he's he after this match
here he will be the last young Indian
player still standing I believe I
haven't looked at the bracket in a
minute but I think so
yeah he's gonna have to carry it forward
but he has quite the track record in
both the jscc and the SEC having
defeated the likes of Alexander gristook
and of course having defeated a couple
of pretty decent players in the cgc on
route to the finals yep
all right so what we have here is a
an imbalanced affair for the ages a tale
of Zelda's time my friend the Battle of
Bishops and knights Knights versus
Bishop who is better
what movie is that I I there's no movie
I'm just when I'm talking about a tale
as old as time I like to talk with an
accent that
puts me in a place of
that when you are are are you making a
movie reference you know you have to
realize you know who you're dealing with
here total ignoramus you know I mean
you've seen less movies than Gary
kaspora you know it's saying a lot
it's weird for you to refer to yourself
in the third person Gary in the third
person yeah
okay h66 Magnus driving that H Pawn up
opening up the file is he gonna go to
which one is he gonna go G4
he might and I think he very well yeah
because Knight takes that four king F3
and you're winning both nights are
hanging great before and G5
let's go buckle your speed belt no you
don't really want to take D5 and then
play g-board but I'm thinking of this
light just G4 G5 here come the Bishops
here come the fun
Magnus is calculating it you you can
kind of sense the wheels turning yeah
and he's a perfectionist you know a lot
of players would just kind of in this
match situation yeah whatever I don't
really have to calculate it Magnus wants
to strive for perfection in every game
and that goes back Danny to your point
about watching greatness and yeah not
always just watching a match because
you're expecting to see overtime that's
not the only way to enjoy a match like
this yep you see a lot of instructive
moments a lot of opportunities to apply
things to you again by the way he does
go for G4 and spying this diagonal idea
this is super tricky for black it may
have even a G4 may have been better
before Bishop D5 I don't know but we
won't criticize Magnus here he's he's uh
in a pretty good spot
um yep and now you could throw in F
takes G6 if you want an end game
now I thought maybe rookie one and queen
D5 check picks up the F Pawn with
interest but there's maybe queen of
three and I get C6 no but then you have
Queen G4 so who knows
uh
which is interesting
you say interesting when you don't know
what's going on but it makes you sound
smart
right interesting is one of those
favorite go-to words of chess players
that only chess players like to use in
any situation yeah yes
it's such a funny word chess players are
obsessed with like a set of words that
stem from uncertainty right right but
you don't exactly want to say you're
uncertain so
the same thing
I agree you're getting the lines called
for with queen of three but okay good
questions oh it was rookie seven first I
wonder why I think that I saw down game
yeah interesting okay rookie seven
rookie six interesting complications
yeah this is a rook ending a rook ending
that's good for white
you know it's interesting would be three
maybe
no no no no no no no no no no
that's not the wagukesh
you can check on C7 or play Rook B6
first
yeah operations C6 Rook F7 maybe ah
Rookie of seven
that'll do the trick
but you have to reckon then with the
possibility of blackhead and connected
passers I just feel like whites white
might have triple my wife's gonna have
Irish pawns white does have triple Pawns
I didn't even realize that is Irish
pawns a term you're allowed to make I
don't know I don't understand it I
haven't I haven't gotten canceled for
yet but I don't even understand what it
means I don't know it's tripled like
it's been introduced to me as triple
pawns but I don't know exactly what it
stems from okay giving up all of his
pawns there he goes we won't we won't uh
goodbye Rook b3b5 close your eyes and
win yep and the King marches from E4 to
G5 doesn't even want to see Magnus play
it out
and another one and we see a 13 game
lead for the world champion
um smarter chess stats had
had a
margin of Victory similar to what we are
on Pace for here
um and again that's what match play is
all about especially fast match play uh
where or at least
G3 and then G4 see that's what I wanted
to see from gukesh early in the match
this is how I thought he should have
played from the very beginning yeah
these types of ideas
foreign
agreed G3 and then G4 and by the way the
eval bar is not lying right those Hips
Don't Lie white white has a bit of an
edge here within attack you can play H4
it's one of the one of the risks of this
early castles for black and these Queens
gamma declines as modern chess players
understand it you wouldn't see this
happen 50 years ago but these these
computers right the the machine learning
neural net artificially intelligent
overlords have said go aggressive or go
home and that g-pawn is often just
thrusted now shout out to you Mom and
yard of daddy shots let's go for an
attack
it's pretty local loca loca but it's
working out perfectly Magnus didn't
react too well
and I agree this is this is the
Practical approach we want to see from
gukesh get some pressure can you just
take D5 you absolutely can that's a free
pawn and another one might be coming
Magnus is basically saying look white is
suffering from a lack of development and
now White's King doesn't have too many
safe prospects but it doesn't need to
have safe prospects because look at
black skin yep
I'm surprised good question about the
pawn instead of that night but I guess
he still wants to take on e4
um yeah
six of course the df6 bishop H6 yeah
you might have to move your king if
you're Magnus if you put your queen on
F6 then I think White's gonna take twice
using the fact that the Knight then does
not have the F6 Square very nice like it
I love it I want some more of it
this right here is exactly what kukesh
wants you have to drag Magnus into
positions where he's relatively
uncomfortable and Magnuson uncomfortable
don't really go together
in any sentence but this is so they do
have to switch his chairs or switch to
the couch yeah so don't really switch it
he just switches chair of their couches
too
allows Bishop takes H6 I couldn't tell
if that was a fake laugh by you or not
but either way I appreciate it my kids
do that for me too my life is always
genuine Danny would you say something
funny I would never stoop solo as to
engineer a fake laughs it wasn't funny
why not take H6 first
I think Knight G4 maybe was on the
horizon
okay
and there wasn't like
like Rook G4 fg4 Queen E4 takes H6 Queen
G6 a lot of minor pieces hanging though
including that I don't have three in
that position okay okay fine
um
touche
okay now Bishop H6 again there's Knight
G4 and then maybe your idea
is more pertinent in that position of
Queen E4 right there but no between E4
Knight H6 you have to play Rook G wait
no
okay
you can play Bishop G7 and if King takes
H3 and the Knight is pinned oh
that's a cool idea
I don't know
I mean 95 is more pedestrian but also
probably possible let's show Bishop H6
on the analysis board yeah Bishop page
six Knight G4 yeah Queen E4 no but Queen
E4 I can play Knight H6 that's that's
what I'm saying so you so you have to
take G7 but then
now
yeah but this type of position is
already okay maybe not going to F6 maybe
bishop F5
but that's really necessary F4 Rook F4
uh
uh that's a nasty one it's I mean you
still see the email more being as close
as it is just to show that that was it's
not an easy position for black and given
that Magnus is down a minute on the
clock I I'm still giving gookesh pretty
good chances here he didn't go for the
most aggressive option of Bishop H6 but
you have to keep the pressure you got to
keep the funk
let's go
the problem here is that if black can
consolidate then White's finally gonna
you know pay the price for that early G4
move of course gukesh could Orient
himself toward queenside Castle but
clearly that doesn't solve all of his
problems
he is doing orienting Michelle and he
does
nice
Russia
okay Knight 65 what is here waiting for
whoa
give me pins or give me death let's go
come on come on
maybe there was a better move than E3
maybe bishop B4 that's what I wanted I
wanted pressure on that night while
there was still a pin with the queen and
the Rook Rook on D1 spying them oh
Bishop B4 it's coming C5 but after
Bishop C5 and Bishop G8 Danny I could
take and then pin your queen in the end
side analysis real quick bang bang
knight B6 Bishop B4 C5 Chop Chop Bishop
G8 doing the lady
Rook ACA so frustrating and pull me
again a space
that's that's all right literally not
what you would say there with that
accent that is literally not what you
would say
gosh we have so much work to do
um the Irish are not happy I mean all
right
accent okay Magnus is under 10 seconds
though I'm openly rooting for you cash
here to get the dub no shame let's go I
wonder what kind of Pawns we're gonna
get after F take C4
it's my Island what does he say in
Braveheart he's like that's my Island I
can't even do the Irish accent I'm the
right person to ask what what what's
something in an obscure that guy saved
that movie you know we were we were way
down the rabbit hole of Mel Gibson
monologue oh he takes in place no no no
he didn't take why didn't kukesh take
any four now Queen takes C6 and he's
given Magnus a chance to consolidate
unbelievable you can even take a three
now if you're black so white has to take
back with the queen but now Magnus is
totally fine with this bishop out of the
game okay but here comes Rick G7 five
seconds for Magnus he has to defend that
pawn queen E7 probably whoa G5 and we
live hey Canty here we go play E4 don't
chase he can play he takes F3 he can get
away with that
only Magnus only Magnus play E4 and then
H4 E4 because the queen as well yes now
H4 just do it
you called it I think H4 is the only way
you have there you go let's go G6 but
Magnus is going for his vintage Queen
trade
ah Magnus ah so frustrating and now I
think Mukesh is losing control of the
game but he gets his King up just in
time okay five seconds Rook F1 no he's
back in seven book F3 now okay white has
the Bishops and E5 is coming but careful
don't blunder your Bishop I like this
re-maneuvering of the bishop Here Comes
E5 now Bishop F3 Bishops high pressure
Bishop G2 Bishop H3 I love this good
play by good cash Bishop C5 Check Yes
Force the king back King E5 yeah but
here you go 97 no oh no did I I messed
it up now it messes up outside passer I
don't know who's better here White's got
two passers and they're more mobile but
Black's got the outside passer and you
have to be careful of this A5 B4 C3 idea
here it comes and there it comes he's
got to go back but now Bishop F7 Bishop
E6 is so nasty to trade off the Bishops
no he's gonna lose
the H1 slip no oh Magnus fluttered he
had H3
what's going on four seconds for Magnus
two three seconds two seconds he goes
before first and whoa he's gonna play A4
oh my gosh he's got trousers but so does
go cash
G7 G7 White's winning it's made for
white where's the mate though I don't
know but it's gotta be there oh my God
oh my gosh
oh
oh no he cannot catch a break he did
everything to win that game it was
completely winning just queen f8 queen
D6 Danny and then E6 like literally
anything was winning there
oh my God and Magnus takes a drink of
the water I slide down in my chair
that is absurd absurd
absurd absurdist on Mufasa oh Mufasa say
it again
dude after that game I have three mice
on my table
I think they would have been in 800
pieces
after that
oh my gosh it's 16 to 2.
that is ridiculous
yeah this is this is going to be the
last match of the three plus one segment
after this of course we will have bullet
shout out to Captain Edie with the three
month subscription I just saw a chat for
the first time shout out to all of our
subscribers who might be subscribing
throughout the day that we didn't call
out
um I just looked at the chat bro Magnus
destroyed
um yes chat there is destruction going
on
I really want to see someone take that
moment from Lion King with the hyenas
and and dub it over to be Magnus instead
of Mufasa say it again if someone throws
that at me you get a one-year Diamond
membership on Twitter
okay don't be a little a little
Photoshop a little GIF action Mufasa it
is Magnus did you get a you get a
diamond
holy smokes Queen C6 mate that's gonna
be in go Cash's nightmares tonight
that's for sure
yeah
Queen H1 a C6 mate
what good play here for cash he's not
tilting yeah it's a good position he
actually is still giving it his all
and
you know what we do a lot for his
confidence to end the three-minute
segment with a win obviously the result
of the match not really in question
but hey there is enough time I think to
play 13 bullet games so you never know
you never know you never know
Bishop to G7 from goo cash you're right
this is a good position for black the E5
Pawn is a target
white also fine but gukesh is uh he
hasn't tilted I think I saw Chad say
earlier we're mentioning he's keeping
his composure always looking good
looking Dapper but but this is this is a
tough spot to be in
it it most certainly is
it's unenviable you're just looking at
the match score
you know and again you know you don't
get an easier opponent in the bullet you
just get the same opponent again
we should do a little bit of like The
Masked Singer how about next time we do
a side a side of him for SCC it's it's
the SEC except when it gets to Bullet
you don't know who your teammate is you
get up and someone else sits down could
be anybody right it could be me I have
to play the boy
is kind of having a meltdown here in
this final game
yeah this is this is going to get gukesh
the dub he needs to head into the bullet
to keep us all on the edge of our seats
Magnus is dropping the pawn on E5 and
once that pawn drops the floodgates open
yeah who cash better take that pawn or
else we're gonna have a problem okay
okay thank you kudash thank you okay
Magnus if Magnus recovers from this game
I'm gonna be
I'm running out of adjectives to
describe how I'm going to be
you hungry you hungry for victory you
hungry I am hungry
some uh
um
yeah Magnus is the one eaten this whole
time someone should tell him like you
know hey save some room for later
Augustus he was doing well mvl is like
the originator of the meme right just
like the whole snacking wild thing he's
just he's just incessant and I remember
when he won that match the first time we
were commentating on it it was back in
2017 and like we had him show his spread
he literally had made himself like a
charcuterie board it was like cheese wow
meats and like nuts I was like what is
going on here it's amazing
yeah yeah you want to make sure though
that whatever you eat during a match
isn't like greasy because there's
nothing worse than having to wash your
hands after every bite that you take
because you because then your laptop
plus increases the chances of a mouse
slip right I mean the sporting aspect of
Chess cannot be underestimated in these
online formats it is true like there's a
sporting you know it's not exactly the
traditional sport Esports I guess but
there's a sporting aspect to how these
guys handle their time pressure and you
don't want your feet your fingers greasy
nope you don't want a piece of chicken
fingers stuck on stuck on your keyboard
in critical moments
absolutely all right there should be one
here
um kangaroos walking about Walkabout I
have a bad feeling about this game on
Google Cash's behalf I don't know why I
don't know why you shut your mouth when
you're talking to me I ain't the prophet
for nothing you know they call me that
for a reason that's they shushing shush
in your mouth
don't you don't dare call a Magnus come
back here Rook C3 maybe try to get some
counter play down the C file but dukesh
could actually Park his King on B6 even
and support the Knight with Rook C8 and
close close the doors the time ticks the
more I get nervous about what you said
oh and this is just what Magnus does he
just never ever ever dies doesn't matter
how many pawns you win you'll find a way
to mix things up
Mufasa
can be seven maybe one can be seven guys
that was good all right play G3 if your
magnets just hold on to the pawn and
make goo catch blunder
wonder and maybe blunder yeah just like
put the pressure back on the kid he's
got 30 seconds and I would do if I was
Magnus I'd play G3 and just sit tight
although is 94 coming and just
simplifying
I'm just trying to find a word that
rhymes with blunder and wonder well
black is going to tear white asunder
what was that with the move d4
down under Heaven Queen D2 is idea but
then Knight E4 I think 94 ends it Queen
D2 94 is a four
of the queen and Rook that is a forking
problem last time I checked
I'm slipping my propheticious spat in
the face of my so-called prophetic
powers
hey it's Okay We're not gonna hold it
against you
I have to make some controversial claims
yeah it's over Knight T4 he's gonna give
a peace
just quintix D4 even as simple
resign time
Knight D3 no then Rook takes D3 Rook
takes C1 yep good calculation yeah
and go cash with the honor goal in the
final game
of the three minute portion he takes it
right so we uh that's right that's the
start of the comeback in the bullet
portion you don't want to go anywhere a
comeback can't start without one single
victory
and uh right now ukash has taken the
last three minute game home he gets up
to take a walk Magnus was out of his
chair before you could say uncle and uh
he has a lead scoring eight points
respectively in each of the 5-1 and 3-1
segments that's uh that's pretty good
chest there from Magnus Carlson Dania
yeah I mean this is just a dominant wire
to wire performance
Magnus was playing with such verbs such
comp such just looseness in the 300
portion but in in a good sense of the
word it was just a unbelievable
performance but there's enough time for
13 games in the bullet and you most
certainly do not want to miss a OnePlus
One display from the world champion so
it's a win-win no matter how it goes and
I think no matter what we will get some
exciting games some exciting finishes
and entertaining chess by a couple of
the best players in the world so you
know what else is going to be
entertaining what's that Danny the state
of Chess our next state of Chess it's
been a minute you've been waiting for it
it's the quarter four state of chess for
the year of 2022. it's coming to you
live on December 21st we have some huge
news for the chess Community I'm not
kidding this time and the event will be
followed by a Community Q a with yours
Julie plus some very special guests will
be joining us on the show to talk about
these exciting announcements we're going
to be making these announcements talking
about the future of a lot of things
we're doing here for the chess Community
you don't want to miss this show on
December 21st at 10 A.M Pacific time I
would I would name drop some of the
guests that will be there but that might
give away some of the things we're
talking about so I'm not going to do it
you can find the action at twitch.tv
chess you can sit right where you are
don't go anywhere or I will find you
continue to watch this show at twitch.tv
slash yes because John you and I will be
right back
any move can be the last you make
in a war of the mind you must adapt to
change
every mistake made an opportunity to
strength check and when the ash is
settled
only one will be crowned the victor
check me
Victory oh Jesus
foreign
[Music]
within the Tempest the best have come to
test their skills and brave the storm
oh my goodness the wheels the wheels
have come out that could be the match
for some this is familiar ground oh my
goodness 98 whoa
for others this is a Fresh Field to
prove their prowess this is insane oh
look at Fabby
electric six oh that was a sick tactic
the moves will be fast it's game over
it's winning oh my God he's gonna make a
queen the stakes will be high he just
grabs his head he can't believe it he
just gave away the pawn the 2022 speed
Chess Championship is now
fasten your speed belts my friends we're
in for a wild ride
it is the speed Chess Championship in
the year of 2022 Danny wrench here
alongside Grand Master Daniel nerdinsky
we've had quite the Magnus Carlson
performance today we still have bullet
ahead Donya what do you expect the final
score to be at the end of the Cub the
upcoming fastest segment
man I mean Magnus has scored eight
points in both of these segments if he
keeps it going he's gonna score more
than eight points in the bullet at this
point I think gukesh's goal should just
be to make the bullet competitive try to
go 50 and keep this lead to what it is
right now score a couple of nice
victories yeah you want to score a
couple of nice victories unfortunately
if our pre-match prediction holds up
which is the kukesh probably had his
best chances in the slower time controls
that really wouldn't wouldn't spell good
things uh but we'll see if if we were
wrong and he can he can impress the
crowd here in the fastest portion of the
speeches Championship our players are uh
are back at the board Magnus has I don't
know what he was tussling with at the
break but his hair is it's like he's
trying to lead into the meme here
you sure he came out of the shower in
the beginning of the match
you shower you put on a hoodie
you take off the hoodie
um yeah but you comb your hair after the
shower you should comb your hair that's
actually the point of showering yeah
your hair is more combable
but uh Magnus not too stressed about
that given the score of this match
he now has the black side of this uh
kind of Pierce looking position where
White's gonna attack on the king side
this should be a fun spicy one to kick
things off in the bullet for sure and
gukesh himself has been known to play
this with the black pieces this time
he's on the receiving end of a modern a
great opening for bullet honestly
because it's easy to Rattle off a bunch
of moves if you're black there's kind of
a stock Queen side attack yep and Magnus
opting for the early trade oh I don't
know about queenside castle here
you're walking in to the attack but at
this point anything you can get that
that has double edged chances right you
want three result positions if you're
goukash to give yourself a chance to get
a victory you might lose but you still
want those types of positions to give
yourself to give yourself any any kind
of fun even if we're not having a
comeback Right Here Comes E5 and F5 and
launch the attack Young fella yep and I
like I like ukesh's speed in the early
going he's not overthinking it he goes
F5 and then E5 oh Magnus opens up the
center this looking mighty dangerous for
black now yeah but
Bishop takes B5 as possible I think
Knight takes B5 might be a move as well
but not just banking on yeah he doesn't
go for either of those but that was
there was some spicy potential there
instead he goes for the forcing line but
kukash grabs a pawn and kukesh could
absolutely check my Magnus here oh wait
Queen H6 we need six at the back oh
Magnus rolls his head
to follow up he goes 94. by the way Rook
takes H6
sorry pointing up yep no no that was
important but it's it's not totally over
I've seen crazier things happen in
bullet yeah and gukesh kind of imprecise
to follow it up
yeah oh Queen D1 and queen D5 what's he
allowing
I thought Magnus should have traded
Queens he wasn't expecting Queen D2
gokesh is still up a piece let's let the
record state right no he didn't follow
up correctly but he's still up a piece
but there's a lot of forks here and
Magnus has quite a quite a few pawns so
okay he's gotta guess
yeah if he doesn't win this that would
be a travesty yeah Bishop you should
have played Bishop of one if you can't
yeah just keep all your pawns yeah get
get greedy uh I don't know about that
move
Magnus is going to start pushing his F
Pawn Bishops
you're you're suffering from a little
bit of Magnus bias itis I think she's
gonna get this D3 D3 no but that's why
he's blundered his piece oh no it's
still winning it's still completely
winning okay
he's got to check what's your a pawn
no 94 it's going the wrong way all right
he's losing all of his pawns and here
comes the F Pawn oh now it's anybody's
game
what is happening
what is happening King G7 and if A7 Rook
A6 Magnus is playing for the wind Magnus
is winning
no way this just happened no no no no no
no no no no no he's still in the game he
can give up the H6 Pawn for Rook f8 I
think Knight F5 ah but then the king
moves and the bishop can step in to B5
so it's go cash now the one hanging by a
thread
wait what what did Magnus just do just
yeah th7 why did he take
Knight C7 I don't understand anything
that's happening here it's really
nothing okay now go cash just simplifies
those show you the nerves he's like I'll
give up my room for the night I'm not
over Kesha needs to find the right
winning construction
okay okay he's got it with Bishop D1
okay and finally for the record or the
record for those tuning in damaraju
gukesh has won two games in a row
yep for the first time this match I'm
just saying what is that thing they do
where they go like
just just say you know wasn't that a
thing for a while where you just go like
like I thought or is that
is that like a new Taylor Swift meme
going around
Taylor Swift and meme that just
departing from my area of expertise
quite drastically Hooters that was a
ridiculous game yeah
Emily Magnus was winning there at the
end
and he just gave up a rook
yeah the chest the chess Karma equalized
itself though it felt like Poetic
Justice would be served gookesh you guys
should have won that game I mean queen
H6 come on that was a beautiful move
right you got you got to win that game
gukash's mistake was not to follow up
accurately If he if he had played Knight
D5 the game ended immediately you just
can't give Magnus you know multiple
opportunities even if you're up a piece
against him you got to try to finish him
when you when you have the chance
well right now
24 and a half minutes just under 25
minutes really for good cash to mount
the absolutely most improbable comeback
in the history of the universe of all
things exactly
but okay
um
hey Google's this one it's a three-point
uh streak yeah three points in a row
probably I feel like I feel like I'm
talking I feel like I'm the manager in a
major league lecturing my team that like
if you win again that's called two in a
row if you win again that's called a
winning streak and I know we've never
been there before yet chat but if we get
three games in a row for gukesh that's
called a winning streak uh this is
called losing the game right now it's
not happening nope not happening mate
that's going to be happening pretty soon
but go cash now trying to pull a Magnus
from the previous game
Knight F5 Maybe
wait Queen the queen on C6 It's Not Over
King H3 by Magnus says I will unpin my
Bishop come hell or high water let's go
and my Rook he unpins both pieces at the
same time and puts his King on the
safest Square on the board
yeah
yeah he's gotta find a way here Bishop
E5 Queen E5 and queen h8 is an idea that
would be fun
between CA check actually that's easy to
blunder in a bullet game I think Magnus
might be blundering it
if he goes for this with Queen h8 Queen
c h i can see a check okay now I think
he's seen it oh oh oh did he go for that
thinking he had it
and that means his King is now once
again kind of stuck in the danger zone
yeah but he's gonna win okay no he does
get out of it yeah that's that's a
that's a comment from future chat I have
to call out even in adoption by gukesh
winning 10 games in a row would not be
enough to turn the tables in this match
I think not even close to enough I think
I can retire on that note I I mean if
adoption can't save it who can save this
this little offering kit over here yeah
that's kind of a mic drop comment right
there yep ah all right well Magnus does
right the ship after losing two in a row
we will not have our first winning
streak for the young goo Kesh uh we are
back in our
kind of Queens Gambit looking position
here
Moran ideas Advance the beeple and push
C5
and you can try to farm some bullet
rating off of Magnus I mean that that is
a juicy rating right there well you're
always thinking about farming that
rating you know always I can't switch it
off
it's second nature
you know you got one thing on the brain
down there you always have it's that
leaderboard before
chess.com leaderboard is calling it
wants its number one spot for Don you're
back
yeah but bullet ratings I mean they
swing wildly and Magnus hasn't played
too much bullet on chess.com but maybe
that'll change after this segment yep
well it's been a lot of title Tuesdays a
lot of Blitz
not not a lot of bullet
the boulay
a Boolean Kelly once again are you
putting the wrong Impossible on the
wrong syllable syllable yeah that's
exactly what I'm doing
yeah
honest he's a 2900 first thing he thinks
is Farm all right it's an arable rating
his Queen trap you're just happy to see
me Oh I thought Bishop D6 was oh Queen
E6 down okay so he trades Queens instead
converts to the end game classic Magnus
trade
okay now he's threading to take twice
and end up with two pass pawns on the
queen side
but the underlying the elephant in the
room is that there's Pawn on C3 is
eventually going to win the game because
there's just no way to break up the pawn
chain and the Knights jumping into B5
take a seven though I think
yeah no choice I don't know what what
gukesh is yeah thinking about
take it okay there you go there we go no
but he's completely double on the a file
oh you should have doubled first prevent
Rook A8
[Music]
goodbye uh oh
rock and roll now
Magnus writes the ship in the bullet and
now he's up 2-1 in the bullet segment as
well
just kind of coasting
well we will uh we will
likely have some exciting games here for
last minutes we will also likely have an
interview with the world champion Magnus
Carlson so you don't want to miss that
don't go anywhere of course we have
under 20 minutes now remaining in this
match and also remember the new rule
this year for the first time in SCC
history I finally relented and allowed
the option to resign a match if you want
before that it was forced I don't know
the gukesh will I think he wants every
single game he can get against the world
champion and I'm like Russell Crowe
screaming are you not entertained here
I'm happy to get more games no matter
what the score is but no matter what we
will have an interview with Magnus
Carlson so don't go anywhere to see that
yeah and and as good cash should want
every game possible against the world
champion it's just such a treat for
anybody to face Magnus and it's not in
the greatest of circumstances here for
gukesh he's not going to be happy with
the score but
you always just get a rush from from
playing Magnus in any time control in
any situation and I think he's finishing
the match
I mean I'd be looking at that score I'd
be thrilled right okay we're not talking
about me here I'm like I got four points
what are you kidding me yeah exactly I
ain't I ain't going away
yeah unfortunately he seems to be going
away in this game the Knight potentially
jumping into D6 forcing Bishop f8 but
you cash has this F4 Square for his own
horsey whoa what is Magnus doing that's
a free night
he just killed up the night on F5 I
don't need it nobody raises his own hand
like I don't know what I was thinking
there I mean I don't make any sense I
guess he wasn't expecting G6
um this is still a little double edged
though
Donya I don't know if this has been
mentioned yet
but
there hasn't been a single draw in this
match
oh
that's nuts I didn't stop to think about
that that's a great observation
only decisive games have been played in
this match has that ever happened
in the history of the speeches
Championship stat boy yo give me Vaughn
that's right give me Vaughn can I get
Vaughn in here can I get statboy can we
get someone on that stat
oh good cash has let the spawn slip into
A7
oh
and eat to your point Danny I think the
answer is no I mean if I had to bet I
would bet that the answer is no that
it's crazy for a match and we could
still get a draw I mean probably I'm
jinxing it right now classic comic
exactly as we speak but that is
that's kind of crazy
it is King F1
what's crazy is that Magnus might win
this down a full piece we're not going
to see a draw here
if we see a draw in this game that would
be absolutely nuts I would go F4
okay Magnus going after the piece
takes on F2 where's the attack coming
now though it's somehow fizzle out into
a draw I could see this getting into a
Perpetual be hilarious if right when we
call it mid game that that game we have
an end game we have an email bar sliding
back Magnus back on the prowl no but
we'll catch it deep on really lost his
mind here Donna is dancing on d8
you know no draw
Donna as in Donna Summer it's a problem
it's not Donna ship F6 Dirty Dancing
Bishop c72
oh Bishop oh Danny's sick King takes F6
d8 equals Bishop mate mate if you go
mg's or snaps he's under promoting to a
bishop for mate
oh G5 by Magnus which is not a bad
bullet line here we go for for the
alakyne will we get a ball in Cloud can
we get a can we get a poll for chat will
we get a bond Cloud before we're done
here
um who do you think he is Young Kristoff
Duda yo stuff dude
stuff
I'm sorry I didn't mean to correct you
forgive me I didn't mean to do it in
front of still 15 000 people on Twitch
and please do people on YouTube I love
being corrected I'm sorry I'm sorry
okay
five uh
uh
yeah
[Music]
awesome
wow
not bad I didn't know I spoke as much
Russian as I do did you I did I know you
knew you know all the pieces and you
know all the squares I have uh some a
little bit of vocabulary still listening
do you know how to say it do you know
how to say f takes E6
uh uh uh beautiful
all right here we go
um do you know how to say blunder
uh I do just stop squeezing me on the
spot and sheep is good enough it means
mistake leave me alone it's the same as
the word for yawn
oh really like like you're tired like
yawning yeah there's a funny story
um my coach told me
um an old guy was playing I don't know
if this is like apocryphal or what old
guy was playing a game
and uh he he he was so sleepy he yawned
so widely that he had a problem with his
jaw and had to be transported to the
hospital and when he woke up the doctor
told him well you know you're in the
hospital because you yawned and
literally in Russian he said what did I
yawn because it's the same as what did I
blunder oh I get it I love it hilarious
I know this everybody's this is like the
uh the old you know proverb of of
sacrificing a knight you know what is it
you come to like the crossroads and you
either have to lose a knight or like
choose death or something
what is going on with those nights
I don't remember
I don't know someone was talking to me
about their feelings I wasn't really
paying attention
um in the meantime Magnus has slipped in
another victory
Luka doncic Style with that Euro Step
with the Knights moving in that's my new
thing is I started I was watching Luca
doncic dominate my sons last night a bit
of a bit of a Luca fan here despite him
consistently dominating my sons he plays
on chess.com
shout out to Luca playing on chess.com
every day but I was watching Luca
dominating wait wait wait wait he does
yeah
Luka doncic plays on chess.com did you
not even see his interview from a couple
weeks ago I did not yeah and he and I
asked him if he's following the Twitter
collapse of Elon Musk and he said I play
chess on my phone wow so Luca plays
chess on chess.com but he also dominates
the sons for a living for breakfast and
I was watching him do a Euro Step and I
was like that's like a night move bruh
so I'm I'm bringing it in I'm bringing
I'm bringing sexy back I'm bringing Luca
into every chess match
Golf Club
exactly
okay okay here we go here we go Magnus
has the white pieces here and rosalimo a
rather dignified opening for a bullet
game they went from alakyne with G5 to
like a mainstream rosalimo
yep and uh
I don't even know what to make of this
Pawn structure those double d-pawns are
dirty you can take it if you're Magnus
you can okay he does
upon
and there's going to be no e-pawns after
gukesh finishes taking it
yes the Knight comes into F5
though so I don't exactly know how that
happened I was too busy talking about
Luka doncic but black gives up a pawn
97 check by the way is a possibility for
Magnus as a way to try to get to that
Bishop on E5 this game might be the
closest we've come to a draw I have a
feeling that they might get some sort of
liquidation yeah
okay will we have the first ever SCC
match in history without a draw he says
before checking stats I've asked for Von
give me stat boy check on that but I'm
pretty sure I'm right
um says before all the pieces get traded
and we get a draw
or will we have
a blunder
Ed end game yeah it's a three result
game for sure yeah Bishop coming to D3 I
don't know if we're getting a draw
I think Magnus gonna pull this one out
again Bishop D3 here you go you called
it oh Bishop oh he goes back into ooh
Rook F6 very nice what about that twist
okay he's gonna put the King on D4
and that Rook is going to be ensconced
on F6 look at that
anchors it in who cash can't move and he
gives away A6 oh no why why
he's just collapsing here again Imus is
gonna win this again
What It Takes B4 give me those Pawns
I wonder why he did that
yeah why
exactly Jan exactly yeah yeah you know
in 1972 Mikhail girovich yeah I was
talking to him he was playing in a
Robert Huebner with the time and the
funniest thing about Hooper Janice
exactly Jen was that uh yeah sorry and
and huevner uh he came to the board and
He adjusted his glasses
thick German accent of his butt opening
are you playing Jen it was the funniest
scene and Johan harderson who was
sitting next to them
that not a lot of people know Jen is uh
anyway sorry here we go we can just do
this forever
I want to see your Yasser say Mufasa you
want to see what Yasser SEI Mufasa I
feel like he'll say it in the most
soothing possible blanking if you didn't
know it was actually the highest rated
animated movie of all time yeah exactly
Jen I love the scene where where the
hyenas say Mufasa oh
reminds me
of when I was scared the one time I was
playing for the Olympia team and Gary
Gary kasperoff came in the back door
because Pera because no one was allowed
to go in the back door Mufasa
but Carrie but Carrie had special
privileges in the Dubai in 1980 and I
remember the paparazzi you know
shattered me out the door after I beat
him
oh man
okay in the meantime this is this has
become a better baseball show where one
team is up by 15 runs and we're just
thinking of stuff to talk about at this
point because yeah
because you know nine minutes to go
it's funny I feel like every year we get
some of the most incredible chess and
and just nail biting drama you get when
you watch the game of kings in the SEC
not kidding I mean you get Armageddon
you get dingly red Nakamura of last year
right but you also get a couple blowouts
and um
you know this is let's hope this is the
last one we see and again gukesh
obviously awesome very bright future for
the young man but you you mess with the
bull you get the horns and sometimes the
horns look like a giant mop of hair
yep and it's just brutal to face Magnus
Carlson in some of your first online
Blitz chess in a while Magnus is having
some internet problems he's gonna flag
this one out
he's lagging out
the internet catches up with him he has
this bad white track he has to fix this
yeah but you can't just call it uh it is
in America you have this uh it makes a
signal it puts out it has a router okay
you're routing your things
reset yes because Magnus Carlson may
have a problem with gigabit the fiber
connection yes very good duh
uh-oh well we've got 17 000 of you with
us here we're about to interview the
world chess champion at the end of this
segment that is Magnus Carlson attacking
him about his victory as well as how he
sees the rest of the speed Chess
Championship playing out for him he's
currently got a 16-game lead Dania as we
head here into the final games of the
OnePlus One portion
I don't know I are talking like a
football announcer all of a sudden but
uh I'm going to join in
God we have got to
we're just all over the place we're all
over the place here we do have some
internet technical difficulties they
don't make a pill for that one and uh
Magnus is gonna have to the dues do some
things the old-fashioned way to maybe
hit that reset button
um you know you call tech support
they're like have you plugged it in and
unplugged it and plugged it back in and
you're like just upgrade me to level two
tech support like I don't have time for
you don't tell me to plug it back in
give me level two to the supervisor and
the manager please they're like I'm
sorry sir but I have a list of
checkpoints that I have to go through
before I can escalate you to level two
agent
agent zero zero zero zero yeah zero zero
zero thanks for telling me that can you
give me a little more information before
I can pass you on
when you look at your router is the
green light on press one for yes two for
no or for the things you don't need
Press Two for the other thing you don't
need and three for the other thing you
don't need and for the only thing that
you would ever be calling for there's no
option no option no option here
oh man
all right well
swagness is
rushing his hair and frustration this is
a good time to experience inner problems
the match is not in question
yeah he could he could lose a game for
every minute remaining on the clock and
he would still be moving on to the next
round okay well um good good questions
will be coming
um reminder chat I'm pretty sure some of
your questions will make it into the
interview process so if you ever wanted
to ask the world chess champion a
question this might be your opportunity
start thinking of them now I'm not in
charge of pulling those questions from
chat but someone crushing it for our
broadcast team the best broadcast team
on the internet I didn't just say the
Chess World shout out to the entire team
making these things happen this is
they're going to be talking about this
in like 10 years from now in the future
they'll be like remember Tanya they're
gonna be like remember when chess was
just on the internet before it was like
in every bar and on every TV and like
there were channels remember that those
guys were the OG Pioneers that's what
they're gonna be talking about in 10
years sitting in you know their sweaty
closet
you know broadcast sitting in their
sweaty closet potato
es to tell about you Robert loves
telling stories where he's next to me
and sweaty
I know I've noticed that as well I'm
glad I'm not the only one who's noticed
that it's a little weird Robert likes to
talk a lot about being sweaty next to me
I'm glad we kicked him off the broadcast
yeah to Echo what I said at the start
there's gonna be some fun matches coming
up though Danny because I love all three
of all three of the ones we've got on
our docket here oh
oh the knee held Geary match I mean
who's a favorite in that match I'm going
with nihal sorry
well it's a Rema you know what makes
this even more fascinating it's a
rematch of their cgc match which nehal
won and I knew you were gonna say that
oh my God I'm trying to remember if it
went out to Armageddon
it did go to Armageddon remember there
was a bid there was a bid and Anish giri
uh ultimately got got white
um but uh
grinded down that Rook ending and
ultimately Swindle Geary all right
remember that so it was an amazing scene
F5 or King G5 whatever black magic key
or just traded to win that end game
the only thing I love more than a niche
than trolling a niche Geary on Twitter
is watching anishikiri win chess games I
love the guy but I believe nihil Soren
is the favorite in this format I believe
in each Geary would probably even say so
himself he has to get a lead in the
early portions of that match or or sarin
will run away with it in bullet I
strongly believe that let's talk about
Wesley so and abuser Turf though because
that is a to me
a matchup where I favor Wesley
but abusive turov that guy the current
world rapid Champion will he defend his
title coming up in Kazakhstan that's of
course at the end of December but I like
abusa turnoff to give Wesley a bit of a
scare there
I actually think that's pretty I mean no
Wesley's definitely the favorite so let
me establish that but in terms of what
these players are capable of if Notre
back plays to the best of his ability I
think we might get one of the closest
matches in the SEC I think we could get
uh something like a repeat of on Drake
and aronian okay I really do
that is one to mark your calendars for
as is of course the second match of the
doubleheader that day some can't quite
read the name at the start is that and
is that is that is that the number one
seed in reigning SCC Champion Hikaru
Nakamura it is versus David paravian uh
Bravia
that was spicy but I am
um there we go it's a double header on
Thursday by the way so if you wondered
what you were doing on Thursday or
whether you needed to call in sick the
answer is yes back to back SEC
championships we also know you don't
have to call in sick these days you just
have it on the backup screen your boss
comes over one button clears the tabs
they can never catch you all you have to
do is press one button and they can't
even follow it even if you're in your
Cube Pro tip yeah or if you are a boss
then maybe you want to encourage your
employees to watch the match to get the
creative juices flowing so my brother
was texting me something funny on the
side sometimes he watches the shows
shout out to my brother
um Beck's calling is hey big you are
producing the shows I don't know what
you're doing I don't know what you're
doing
um
you know abduce that you're off I want
to go back to that because even though
okay I've got any help barely oh we
might have games coming soon I've got
any help barely against Geary I've got
so I think as the favorite against
abdusacharov and obviously Hikaru
Nakamura is the favorite against
perovian
um no disrespecting controversial takes
man controversial takes but yeah we do
have liftoff uh Magnus is going full
Hikaru never go full Nakamura especially
not on a Tuesday
it's a short eight minute flight
until interview International Airport
yep the gate the match clock will start
here in just a moment we've got eight
minutes
on the agenda before interviews with the
world chess champion
yeah and Magnus has been all over the
map opening wise in the bullet he's just
having a good time
finally playing the way I think he
should have played from the very start
H5 I wish we'd seen more of that move
from the Indian Grand Master maybe even
G5 and H4 sacked that Knight on F6 let's
go let's go sacrifice careful
you might have to go Bishop E8 here I
was gonna say I love Bishop E8 I don't
have to use it to me Here Comes G5 uh
Magnus is taking the ladies off the
board he doesn't want to get check
committed he's so greedy even when he's
up like 50 games come on Magnus saves
some room for everyone else save some
dessert for other people he's about to
get checkmated though like this is
literally just oh def what
girl just take it
yeah I don't get that at all cool
um four almost works now it doesn't
quite work we'll get stacking The
Exchange yes yes
give him a rook let's go okay
oh man this is totally winning for black
but Magnus is going to take on F5 you
know how he does it you know Shenanigans
of all kinds you know how we do Bishop
B3
zero one
not one of magnus's finest efforts I'll
put it that way
yeah demolishing
did
did Magnus realize the Rook is pinned I
don't know
Knight F5 is a threat yeah he could have
played Knight F5 on the previous move
and there were some tactics there with
yeah because the D5 uh he didn't want it
because she's like I I don't want it I
don't want any part of that if Magnus
pulls this one out
I swear to God Queen F3 I think is quite
as simple
and strong
all right kukesh
we should do this get down to a Time
scramble
he does it there we go he does it
we're gonna take H3 first
yeah definitely don't take D5 yeah what
is that honestly
oh
seven it's not over yet what is going on
no go cash getting too fancy again all
he had to do was just take on H3 Max is
going to F2 he's trying to provoke black
into losing on time
oh my God is Max Really Gonna recover
something
Wicked This Way blows that's what's
happening still winning it's still
completely winning for black still
yeah too many Pawns
but I feel like we've talked about that
before though when you have to say it's
still winning enough times it's no
longer winning three oh my God
Bishop to beat oh he didn't see it you
should be three
Magnus is just not yeah putting in as
much effort this game he's just he wants
this one Bishop B3 was the chance
for Magnus to do the improbable but he
does go down gukesh strikes and uh a
thousand rating points from that game
yep a thousand a thousand
the provisional rating uh benefit
strikes
oh my God it's supposed to be black this
game what have we got like in a boarding
game
here we go with this again
this is for a chance for me to work on
my dancing eyebrows
that was attempt number two there we go
you know I can lift my eyebrows to the
tune of Macarena Hey Macarena Macarena
Rock Arena did you know that that's a
Funny Talent I have only review you only
reveal this now I know I showed up on
America's Got Talent one day and they're
like what do you do
and someone throws on Macarena
for for years and years what do you
think you think I got a chance someone
called Simon Cowell
I think it's in my best interest to say
yes
and it's in mukesh's best interest to
take the free Center Pawn that Magnus is
offering him
Maybe
oh
what's good catch doing with this bishop
of his
I not know
I fall down dad I don't know Dad I far
down I fall down hard I've hard down
hard dad
another obscure reference
is that another movie reference
okay so this was something I was
supposed to know by your silence shout
out to chess.com subscribing with the
three months here we do appreciate it um
we do appreciate your subscription
seriously subscriptions and premium
memberships are what bring you the speed
Chess Championship and all the events we
do so
that is a that is a truth that is a fact
with your support is how this happens so
we do greatly appreciate your
subscriptions and we do appreciate that
you love the ads I know so many of you
are like Danny I would subscribe but I
love when you play ads because I love
seeing ads for video games that I'll
never play and that makes me happy it
also lets me yell at you Danny so also
Danny thank you for the ads so you're
welcome for those
thank you for subscribing and making
these events happen and thank you for
watching the ads we appreciate you we do
okay
and Magnus appreciates
the magician a little something Knight
D3 Little Queen B1 well how's your
father with 91 check to follow
maybe Rook d8 Rook d8 honor attack in
the night
Tabasco sauce wait a second
oh the queen I was missing the
retreating move I was pulling a Robert
Hess the queen guarded F6
made in one yeah but you're oh you're
threatening 97 so maybe just 48. whoa 27
made your kid stuff made oh my God it
didn't happen the smile on his face
what's funny is we kind of knew it was
coming it was first Knight F6 obviously
I was wrong about the green retreat but
hey let it get away that was crazy
fun fact if kukesh wins this quite
possibly final game of the bullet he
will be higher rated than Magnus bullet
really
also
we forgot to shout out I think that just
ruined smarter chess's predictions for
for sure can we get a we're gonna call
on that really I want to make sure that
Matt is upset out there because that
makes me feel good can we make sure that
smarter chess is wrong about something
is most definitely very wrong about the
bullet aggressively wrong yeah about the
bullet
that's so wrong
um
uh
okay this is gonna be the last game of
the match
and it's purely cosmetic at this point
match was in the bag really from the
first half of the five minute portion
just a wire to wire Victory by Carlson
why are the wire for sure gukesh struck
back in game two if you missed that he
delivered a uh a great performance in an
Italian game and we were like Okay okay
right
um but
wait because he wants one more he just
resigns that's one more game with the
world champion and we do it again those
are those smarter chess scores we had
okay
producer trying to bring us the smart
adjust scores and love it yeah let's
just say that Matt was wrong smarter
chess not so smart today
and if you think about it like after
gukesh won game two game three was also
really really close if you think about
it cash could have won that one
he would have been leading in the match
we could have been singing a different
too and I think chess players always
have this sense of determinism like this
is the way it was meant to be but yeah
when you actually put the pieces
together and you think about it things
could have turned out differently you
just never know what it really comes
down to what was the pivotal result that
really drove the match to go in the way
that it did
yeah yeah Magnus pulling out the upset
exactly
the hair cam
not the hurricane I'm getting close
there
Magnus might might lose this one he's I
don't know what he I don't know what
he's yelling at yelling yelling at
himself
he's like move Magnus move yeah he's
like what is this terrible match score
you made this close maybe E6
igu cash but then I guess Queen B6 comes
in
should be fine oh I wanted Bishop D7 and
then E6 tricks I didn't get it Mufasa
some sort of a Checkmate Mufasa are we
just ending every sentence with Mufasa
now
Magnus it's fascinating
someone's gonna give me a tweet
replacing that scene from Lion King with
Magnus instead of Mufasa and get a
one-year Diamond membership someone's
gonna do it
no I it's a bygone conclusion by the way
the game is over after Queen H4 that
turned quickly it's minus eight because
oh my gosh Here Comes G3
minus eight it's just mate really H Duke
and H1
I think okay is going to resign this one
and he is and that's how it ends folks
what a match what a performance
yeah that
that escalated quickly
um Magnus Carlson brings the queen to H4
he's threatening G3 with Checkmate that
brings our bullet and therefore our
match to a close Magnus Carlson takes it
by a final score of 23-7 with all of our
trolling aside we do appreciate smarter
chefs and the stats they bring because
most of the time they're right in Dania
they were pretty close again
yeah Magnus almost managing eight points
in the bullet segment they play exactly
30 games we talked about it the score
was one to one yeah cash got off to a
great start he did what he had to do but
at the end of the day the pressure the
world champion puts on you from the
beginning of the match to the end to say
it's Relentless is to say absolutely
nothing and Mukesh did his best you know
he put all of his Blood Sweat and Tears
out onto the match but ultimately his
lack of experience coupled to the fact
that you're facing an opponent named
Magnus Carlson that made its presence
felt
yeah well you said it Donya and he did
have some moments some flashes of
Brilliance that game two Italian win we
will always remember along with a few
other a few other big ones I'm sure
gukesh will be back but Magnus Carlson
punches his ticket to the next round he
joins four other players in the
quarterfinals as we can see right there
and he will be taking on an opponent he
knows well shout out to the 2018 World
Chess Championship where neither of
those guys blinked in classical
ultimately it took rapid tie breaks for
Magnus to get the job done Fabiano
caruana who was in chat earlier awaits
Magnus in the next round Daniel
yes he does that's going to be a matchup
of the Aegis one of those iconic you
know iconic matchup of athletes that we
have come to look forward to so much I
can't wait for Carlson carwana just a
couple of cards none of you can a couple
of cars driving their way towards some
great shots all right well we we are
driving our way toward the last segment
of the show that of course is the
interview with the match Victor Magnus
Carlson the world chess champion will be
joining us on the other side of the
break so fans in chat leave your
questions you have a chance to get a
question answered by the world champion
Magnus Carlson via the mediums that are
me and Dania here so leave them for us
we will be right back with the champ and
the final moments of today's SEC match
when we return
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com
connectyourchess.com account and Twitch
account at go.chess.com connect accounts
and bang boom voila you're done 100 AD
free Bliss forevermore whether you're
following our events on site or on
stream type the command connect in the
chat and thank you for helping bring
these shows to life
foreign
[Music]
we are back now here with the final
moments of today's features championship
match and as promised joining us the the
man of the hour the world chess champion
Magnus Carlson Magnus congratulations on
the match
thank you
you're back in the SEC what is it about
the SEC and the format that uh that you
like that you love
uh it's it's a lot of fun to to play
Blitz and this is a chance to to play
long matches uh against uh the best in
the world so
but uh sounds like a recipe for success
how much yeah well you showed a recipe
for Success today Magnus how much do you
enjoy playing uh players who you don't
normally get to face OTB such as gookash
and the players of the younger
generation
um I didn't enjoy today's match one bit
uh I felt like I was playing
horribly from the stars I just didn't
have it at all uh and uh it just
I mean normally I think I'd enjoy the
match but today it was just
it was just really bad
um it was also I mean I was having some
computer issues as well which I didn't I
had no idea what happened like this is a
connection that's been like very stable
for for years so I have no idea what's
going on there
um but yeah generally it was just
um
I mean he's a very strong player but he
has no experience playing
yeah
especially online and uh you know that's
um then you obviously have no no chance
whatsoever but um
yeah I mean I mean from myself like I
don't really I mean
going to the into the match today maybe
I knew I was going to win but I the key
was like trying to play a good match and
I felt like I didn't do that at all and
um that's uh that was um quite this
morning
yep you know I'm glad you touched on
that Magnus Donya and I were talking
about that early on we said that despite
your ability to get some of those
victories it didn't feel like you were
were on your best form and it didn't
feel like you had found found your best
chess what what can you say though about
your ability to get wins even when
you're not playing your best chess and
what how important is that especially in
this format that you find a way to
Swindle your your way to a victory even
if you're actually not playing very well
as as you yourself said was today
yeah but that's I mean
It's a combination of
experience and inevitability that's
still there even when I suck so
no yep
you did get the job done despite despite
feeling frustrated with with your
overall chess but uh one of the things
we observed was that early on in the
match you uh you played this A4 move and
it actually came to us from a from a
question from Anita drink from chat
question was the A4 opening in the first
game of mouse slip or did you deal with
any other Mouse slip problems in the
match
no it wasn't a mile slip like I the last
time I played a speeches Championship I
played against uh para markshuddler in
the first round and then the very first
game I Mouse left A4 and uh so I thought
it would be fun to Mouse slip it again
but
um
shame on us then for not noticing that
because I commentated on that mug sugu
match and I didn't remember at the time
that this was what you played so okay
good good trolling by you Dania I'll let
uh let you take the next feature chat
question we got another feature chat
question Magnus from one godi uh who
asks Magnus what is your hair routine
and more broadly do you have a pre-match
routine that you adhere to before online
matches that makes you feel that gets
you into the zone
foreign
yeah it's a good good question I mean
today I just
[Music]
um
I went for a walk had something to eat
uh then had a shower and and played it
wasn't much more than that like also I
mean I've had
several good night's sleep in a row so
there was no reason why I should be in
in good shape as for my hair you know it
comes and goes
okay
well it had it had quite the personality
today we had a lot of fun so uh we also
had some fun talking about the bananas
you were eating bananas is that what is
your what is your favorite mid mid chess
meal mid-chest snack and bananas are
good for your chest you think
yeah I don't know I just had the one I
just um forgot to
um to eat it at some point I had some uh
some nuts as well
um I think like afterwards and nuts are
probably a good idea in general
um
but um
didn't really didn't really improve my
my playlist
well you did you did get the job done we
hear you so let me before we let you go
we appreciate you having fun with us
let's talk about your last match uh
obviously we know the last SCC didn't go
your way but your next matchup is
against Fabiano caruana uh your thoughts
on what you've seen from Fabiano he
seems to have gotten better and better
every year at the SEC format and what do
you expect to to happen when you face
carwana in the next round
I thought in the first March
um uh foreign
poorly
um against Arjun and then
he started to play he started to play a
bit better after a while so he probably
got got warmed up and
yeah
um I think in general the trend has been
positive for him the last the last few
years since VHS so
I have to
um
yeah I have to show up
yes
well we'll be excited when you do
Fabiana carwana will be we'll be waiting
for Magnus Carlson in the next round if
you just tuned in fans where have you
been uh Magnus you get the job done
congratulations on the Victory and we're
looking forward to several several maybe
great SEC matches again unless Bobby has
something to say about that in the next
round so we'll see you then
thanks Magnus
all right there he was Donya not super
thrilled with his chest today but he did
get the job done there again we see the
final score 23-7 uh your thoughts on on
some of magnus's comments and the fact
that he did get the job done despite not
being on form
yeah I mean that really is like I said
at the start of the match what's most
indicative of greatness isn't how you
play when you're in good form because
everybody at the top level is capable of
a dominant performance yeah Magnus by
his own admission played terribly he was
he was aware that he was missing tactics
during the match he was painfully aware
of it and he wins wins this match by 16
points so his phrase that he knew he was
gonna win that's not misplaced
confidence that's just called Magnus
Carlson being Magnus Carlson that's what
we saw today and arguably that was even
more impressive than an on for Magnus
delivering the crushing kind of
performance that we're used to and
sometimes too that can actually be
healthy when you're when you're in a
position where you're not super thrilled
with your chess you're you're being
super soap reflective about what you
need to do to get better that can have
you in the mindset that ultimately you
look back on and go gets the job done I
mean he just mentioned Bobby on a
carwana started out in bad form against
irokisi and then he won the match right
sometimes that can help early on we'll
see of course if Magnus finds it in the
next round versus because I think he
will need to play better to get past
carwana in the quarterfinals than he did
today so all right speaking of uh
another couple people looking to get
their way into the quarterfinals we have
a matchup going down tomorrow that's
Wednesday December 7th Nihao sarin
versus Anish giri this one is I think
it's going to be close I have a slight
Edge to knee hill
despite uh Nisha gonna throw me on
social media for that your thoughts
Donya well he's going to troll you on
social media regardless so I think I
think let the Twitter war begin this is
going to be a classic SEC matchup and
like I said you know Intrigue is added
by the fact that they faced each other
in the cgc so Anish he's gonna have a
chip on his shoulder nihal is just
knee-hal you never want to miss any
All-Star and match in the SEC and he's
just been playing magically in the last
couple of months so I think we're gonna
have a classic I think this one's going
down to the bullet and there's no better
way to start uh your midweek than watch
I will be just a magical match like that
I will be watching as a fan tomorrow
morning I also can't wait I also think
it comes down to the wire like many I
just can't get enough chess and so if
that's you right now maybe you just
tuned in you're like oh my gosh I missed
the match and oh my gosh I just got the
last moments of the interview with
Magnus Carlson head over to our YouTube
channel right now and uh check out our
premiere of the street chess episode La
Edition that's Los Angeles it's the
fifth and final installment of our
street chess series and it brings you
into the Chess World of the City of
Angels featuring the iconic chess Park
Lounge Street chess La is premiering
right now on youtube.com chess right
after this show uh this I don't know if
you've watched the street show series at
all Donya it's awesome it really is it's
super raw and you know uh gritty stuff I
think it's uh I think it's awesome so if
you haven't checked it out you should
Don yet as well
I most certainly will and I'll be
checking out tomorrow's match once again
from the commentary Booth but Danny the
SEC is just awesome it can't be stated
enough whether we have a blowout or a
really close match as commentators we
want close matches but today we got a
display of a quote-unquote Magnus
Carlson playing terribly winning by 16
points so it's it's good definitely
terribly a win by 16 but uh that's
something he's been doing for for a
couple decades in the Chess World being
very very good at chess so that was
Magnus Carlsen today
for for my partner that was Donya
neraditsky International Master Danny
wrench here uh we we want to thank
everybody for watching remind you that
tomorrow's matchup again as we just
showed is Nihao Sauron versus Anish giri
so tune in then and until next time for
everybody here crushing it working super
hard at the chess.com team have a good
day good night everybody wherever you
are and we will see you tomorrow for the
speed Chess Championship
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]